You
Do I want to be here or do I want to be in my bedroom?
I do not know
Hi
Yeah, I'm trying to figure this out right now. Um
Try to remember my other EA login. I'm very sorry about this. I wish I noticed this earlier, but I didn't
Really think of it as an issue
Hello, hi
Hi everyone
Okay, I'm a little bit so you can hear it, but I hope you guys are doing that. We can at least chat while I figure this out
Otherwise, they'll just play one of the other games that I had planned this week and we'll swap the days
It's not really a big deal. Um
Well, I'm not team for it. Well, I'll plan that another time like I've never played Team Fortress 2. Um, I
Also want to play Gary's Mob with you guys at some point
Let me see if I can find my other EA account hold on
It's just the one I use because I bought it as Rena all my games
I just buy as Rena and I family share over just and that's how we you know own the games and stuff
So we don't have to worry about
Like issues buying games and not owning the games. So I just gotta find it
Well, what's going on, did you have a good day today?
What what do you mean? What?
Oh, like what I never played Team Fortress
I'm sorry. I'll also I'm gonna be a ventriloquist for a second
Why is this
Everything's so low the heck my cats have been messing with my stuff
Before I started stream. I was almost late. Boomi knocked over uh Fia's water and was
stomping on her
It was quite annoying and I'm like he was trying to get to her food and I'm like dude. What are you?
Why do you just you just got fed like let her eat? You don't have to take her food
I might have to start feeding Boomi separately because I think he's been taking rena's food and that makes me mad
Lol I saved the password, but I never saved
A little freaking username. Let's just try it
I
Boomi doing his tail. Yeah, he was he was good this morning. No, I don't want to log in as this
We'll log out
I don't know is it this
Uh
Sign in with that
We're trying we're trying
Incorrect, okay
Okay, I have to do this
Okay, I have to sign in on scheme
Yeah, I'm not a huge fan of EA and everybody knows that like I love Titanfall, but like oh come on, bro
Oh
All right sign in
Yeah, yeah way privacy terms you send a verification
Wait actually
I
Well, I know this for the future
Okay, okay, perfect
I
Sorry, I'm trying to delete stuff
Trying to change my name
Oh
Oh my god, hurry up
Can I change it my profile edit
I don't we will be able to find me. I'm scared. I don't want to be hunt down
Sorry, I'm just like staring into nothing this this is a great beginning to stream
Yeah, yeah, it is it is being annoying right now
Okay, that's fine
Cool
Oh my god, but last time I played was last October what the fuck October 24th
What
No, it didn't work. Oh, I do I have to sign out. Oh my god. I have to sign out of my I have to close youtube studio
I
I'm gonna fucking strangle them
There's something on my tummy
Oh you fucking
You bitch you tricked me. No, I'm going to play Titanfall
I'm just gonna buy it. I just I'll just fucking buy it. I don't care
Add to cart of you my cart
A whopping $30 actually fucking kill me
I mean in minecraft. Oh my god youtube please whatever. It's already demonetized
Get rated get rated. Hi. Hello
Hello
Hi reflens. Hello reflens. Hello
We were just about to start Titanfall, but then I realized that
uh
EA sucks and they don't do family sharing for games
So I'm just gonna buy it again. What sucks is that I bought it when it was like two bucks and now it's $30
so I guess
EA gets its money either way, so
So I'm just buying it off this kill
She didn't want you anymore. It's okay. It's okay reflens. I'll take care of yours
I'll take such good care of you as long story's away. I swear to you. I swear it
I'll give you my off
Um, but yeah, so I shouldn't have to install it again, which is fine
Which I just have to because it's installed on my computer. I thought I could get around it
and just like launch the game
From my other user, but it didn't let me
Oh, it says nothing
You're so sweet. Thank you for the reimbursement. Okay. Mommy needs to go get her credit card. Give me one second
We're gonna put my wallet
Oh
Sweetie, can you give mommy's wallet back mommy needs to buy some some wine coolers
While she hangs out with the girls
sweetie
All right. I'm back
Oh my god, my pillows are messed up, please
I need to support my rear
Can maybe get mcdonald's uh, we have mcdonald's at home
Sweetie, we got mcdonald's at home. Don't even worry about it. I can make you your dino nuggies the way you like them
Don't even worry about it child
It's ready
Titan suit open. Hi sheepy and chat. It's me fun time ferdy and welcome to timefall to the game
What's up, ferdy? All right, uh, let me uh
Two one fight and i'm kidding. That's not that's that way
my thing
I am very pond though, so I would do something like that
Uh
The funny numbers on the back, uh, it's your social security
So can you tell can you tell me what that is? I don't want to save my payment. Actually, I probably should
Because this might happen again if I buy another EA game
Perry the platypus
I don't need to install the content. I already have it. Let me play it
Jesus fucking christ
I
Look so cute and soft. Oh, hi, miwa. Hi. You totally just didn't hear me swearing a second ago. Hi, miwa
Hi, that's that's that's my bunny girl sister. That's miwa. That's miwa
That's miwa
It's miwa everybody say hi and miwa the cute miwa
Priority one scuff the sheebie also. Hello, miwa
Or not. No, you can't do family sharing with EA games. It didn't what the frick is happening here
Oh my god, the game is tweaking out. You guys can't see but there is a rave happening on my screen right now
Oh, it's working serious question if you could get the perms, what persona game would you play if any?
I've never played a persona game
You can shoot me where I stand
This game's already broken. I'm actually going to cry
Oh
Hello, all right. Well, you know memento you'll switch screens in just a moment. Lovely's
Jesus Christ. I don't know what the fuck is going on. Truly. It's gonna be me double for a second
I
Not surprisingly
Oh, I was trying to capture Elden Ring. That's not the
Okay, shut up
I need to change
I need to change this so you guys can hear
Have you seen the new Toblerone? What?
There's a new Toblerone and do we need perms? We don't need really perms for anything
Well, we do that depends what we're playing
You know
My hands are sticky. I don't know why
Yeah, we're not we're not Japanese company. Oh
Oh
Sorry, I clicked off and it just got quiet
Please jesus christ
Turn it down
Okay, that's better
Subtitles on you write about that. Let's do it real quick. I can't read
that's not it
settings video
Um, let me turn everything the fuck down
Um
High ragdolls oh, we don't care what means sun just do medium low fuck medium. It's higher low
Oh, but it's a model detail
Impact marks, I don't really
We want high ragdolls though. That's our priority my 1070 can only do so much. Okay
Wait ragdolls control are physically accurate. Wait, I don't want them to be accurate actually. Let's turn it all the way down
Are they making a timefall three? No, they fucking aren't because apex legends exist because an apex legends sucks
It doesn't suck I just suck at the game
Apex legends is fine to be honest. I like I used to sweat on apex when it first came out
So I'm playing a mouse and keyboard as you guys know my mouse is broken it keeps double clicking so I won't be good
That's my excuse
My excuses. That's my excuse
Uh
Yes, I also liked apex until I knew it kill a timefall three
um
I'll be double tapping. I'll be double tapping
So again, I haven't played in fps
Since well last october so it's almost been a year
Uh, we're gonna do the campaign because do you think I can go into a multiplayer game and
Do it? No, I'm gonna be trash
If I want to do multiplayer lobby gaming
I'll probably do destiny because then I can wipe in destiny because I'm okay. I'm I'm pretty decent at destiny
Um, maybe at some point
I'll do a cod lobby with my dad
No, I don't think I'll do that. Everybody will just be rude to us. I think never mind. I take that back
You guys don't get a privilege. I remove that privilege
Uh
Madam titan protects you asmr
but
Hi there
Pilot, please enter the robot
Pilot, please enter my robosy
Pilot thinks he's in control, but I'm the one who is in control
Sheenie who's sheenie? Yeah, is this real how you just don't want us rosing your dad true
They're little lore bits in apex. I hinted titanfall 3. Yeah, no
No, they only said that that that bt will be in the in apex. They don't say that there'll be a titan
If there is a titanfall 3
I'm sorry. I I am playing the fucking shit out of that game
Just saying
like
I love fps's. I'm not good at them
But I love them because I like how sweaty and like because I used to hyper my
Special interest when I was younger was cs. Sorry. I just bumped my fucking microphone with cs go matches
And I wanted to be a shoutcaster
I wanted to be cloud nine
That was me. She'd be in cloud nine
You know the first
So before I really was a vtuber. I applied with my flush self
And I played a lot of overwatch and I played a lot of cs go and the first companies I applied to were hollow
and vsp vspo
en
Back when they asked for stuff a long long time ago
uh
They actually vsp o uh watched my stuff quite a bit
um
But I'm kind of happy I wasn't selected because I don't think I would have fit in there
And I like where I am now that I can be crazy
Me and hollow they looked at my video
They looked at it hollow watched my my
My audition it was me
Because I never I didn't know what an addition was
I thought they just wanted like a clip of gameplay because again, I'm so used to like
Gaming stuff. They didn't I didn't know they wanted idols
and um
I just sent them a picture of me playing an rpg horror maker game
For two minutes
No for five minutes and then I cut it up and I'm just like whoa. Where is this?
Oh, wow, this is crazy. Ooh spooky. I'm like, no, it was not good
I wasted those people's those people's time and I feel bad. I feel very bad
Yeah, I wouldn't want it any other way. I I am where I belong
Um
Something clicked when oh, uh, I've heard of deadlock. I've also
Wasn't there an FPS game that just came out that was like overshadowed by black myth who kong and it's like called concord or something
Or conquered. I don't know concord
Just kidding this just looks like
Guardians of the galaxy meets fortnight
the heck
What is this?
6% like this video game
It's an epia polish by sony. Okay
Weird
To it. Oh, it's only 700 players. Oh, that's uh
The robot king. He's the robot king
Um, but let me take off my I'm wearing my watch. Let me take that off my tomagotchi is uh, currently sick and dying
It's fine. Don't worry about it. I mean, I'm trying to
dude, the
accidentally turned off my monitor
Fuck
The go XLR is so freaking big
that I have no room on my desk
and
I'm literally gonna
I'm moving my monitors so I have more freaking mouse space
Yeah, moving. Why is there so much litter? Where did this come from?
What the heck is this? There's like a pile of litter on my desk. Oh my god. My cats. I just
and there's like a
Cat claw. I don't even
Where can I where can I fucking put this?
Go XLR too big
Make that smaller. It doesn't need to be that big
Can I borderless windowed this kind of sucks
No, please
Okay, full screener. Okay, whatever. I'll just play windowed then
Yeah, Concord Concord. How am I supposed to know? You just said the same thing
You're spelling it. It doesn't help. Tell me the tone
Zumba needs the ramp. Yeah, accurate
Let me make you guys smaller
Because you guys are ticking up my entire screen and I can't see OBS at all
You little chonkertins
I need a tweet that I'm live
Oh my god, buddy might actually work on Concord finally broken game history. Oh that sucks
Concord. Okay. Thank you
One cord cord drillian players
Concord's bad for a day. Ooh
I think Shawnee's playing that didn't she already play that Concord's bad for a day
I remember I remember that game
I remember watching other people play that game because and I all the stuff going over my head because I was so young
Um, I didn't know that that was like kind of slightly a dirty game
Uh, let's get to Twitter then I never I never tweeted that I was streaming in the first place
But honestly, that's fine. I was doing other stuff. It's not a big deal
Sorry, it's so quiet. It's because I click when I click off it fades away as you can hear
It doesn't continuously keep playing
Oh my god
Come on we are playing
Titan tall Titan tall Titan fall
Two baby
Live rn from saturday night. It's she be
Can I get the link?
Or
Need I need to put up a little red dot so people know I'm alive. I mean that I'm live not that I'm alive
I hope they already know that I'm alive. I hope they know I'm not dead
Although I was dying during the member stream yesterday because people kept drawing
dead people
And I'm like, oh my god, you fucking killed me. Are you fucking and they kept killing my dead?
And but like in a nice way like we would like draw something and it'll be like a picture of like a harlot and like
A bleeding heart like having dinner having a romantic dinner together
But then because we're playing garter phone and then we're playing like the knockoff
Drawings so people would have to like have a certain amount of time to look at something then draw it from memory and then
People would accidentally like just end up drawing things as like dead bodies and I'm like guys. Why did you get like did you bought boomie dead?
I'm like, what is wrong with you? You messed up the snippet. No, I didn't I drew the snippet fine
I thought my snippet was the best. I'm not gonna lie
Yeah, and then people kept drawing with like the shape tool and it was like really bad, but really funny
Anyone would only draw. Yeah. Nope. I was the only one that drew all five members
Everybody else always missed somebody and I'm like, wow
rude
Sometimes it was me and I'm like
Oh
Six shut up, you know what I meant only I said only five not all five
You did it to yourself. No, I didn't I I can go back. I can I saved a bunch of them
All right, I saved a bunch of them. I need to move my big-ass head out the way
I'll throw myself over respawn entertainment. They deserve better, but
yeah, so
um
Yeah, it's in the game
Is that too loud
Of all the things I've seen on the battlefields of the frontier
The pilot is the true dominant force
Yeah, I'm a dominant force
It's fast and agile
Graceful yet devastating isn't like Matt Mercer voices Jack Cooper. I can't recall resourceful
And relentless six the pilot sees the world differently
She will become flanking roots
Pilots fight differently
Experienced in deception. Okay. I played the campaign
About a year ago. So hopefully last October. So hopefully I can remember what the hell I'm doing
So I'm not wandering for hours, but what truly separates the pilot from all the guns and machines of the battlefield
Is the bond between a pilot and a titan?
It's in the robot
Harlan
Oh, sorry, I clicked on youtube studio
When linked to a titan a pilot can only be stopped by overwhelming force or an equal
Shit
The frontier has been the only home I've ever known
The final frontier our lands have been destroyed by the IMC
The YMCA taking our resources
Polluting and destroying our planets
It's funny because this looks like a real
That doesn't look like video game footage. It looks like they just green screen some dudes over it
Which is very interesting to me. It's still it's still like pretty good cinematic
Defeated
Now I say live action. I don't know. I couldn't word fighting to free the frontier
This is all real too. I'm a long way from the pilot
Fact this came out in 2016
I hope I can live up to the honor. I'll go punch
I
Hope I can live up to the titan fall too. Oh, I said it. I'm kidding
Hold on. Let me uh, I'm gonna turn the thing on that so my face reflects the lighting on the screen
No wrong thing
Select
Yeah
Am I too small do I need to be bigger?
I think I need to be bigger. I'm a little I'm a little tiny
Am I echoing?
Why do I feel like I hear a reverb but my stuff isn't on?
I'll press space to continue
All right, let me let me sit up. Let me lock in let me move
Here we go
My name's rifleman cotton bum. She must have power-cycled the simpons since last time. Yeah, we'll have to recalibrate it
Does that feel right to you kupa? Yeah
All right, we're good to go. This is looking up and down how much you remember from last time
Setting the neural link not quite the same as a titan link, but it's similar
Gamer stance
We need to be in the right state of mind. I wish I could raise my
arm rest much. Maybe I need to make myself a little bit taller
No, I'm small
Maybe higher up
I'm pretty control. Yeah, I don't know why someone with the very controls
Okay
Yeah, this chair doesn't have uh
Arm rest uh like raising. All right, technically I'm not supposed to be training you
Yeah
Enabling jump kid assist jump kids. I can't over on yin
Once your jump kid calibrates to your movement style
And the house mobility becomes second nature. I might have to I just realized I might have to cut my nails to play
Because I'm slipping over the what is this destiny inspired by my home planet of harmony. Yeah
Oh
All right
Where's my jump feel weird I feel like my gravity just changed
Well, I would just cut them down and I wouldn't cut them off like I still would have nail polish on
I'm not listening to him. I'm so sorry. Oh, that's ward
Going for golden time trial. Uh, let's see. I prefer the rto one
Let's see how bad I am load your weapon
Oh, yeah, guys, I'm gonna have to cut my nails
Because I can't my fingernails hold on. I'm walking in I was gonna cut them down anyways, they'll just be short
I was gonna have to do this at one point for the
Just
You can focus more tightly on your target
It's also just uncomfortable to play with like a clacky keyboard and long nails
I don't know how girls do it. Uh, I'll be honest with you aim down the sides when engaging more distance
So like I'll I'll let's let's do
Because I only need to technically cut off like two nails. Uh, then people will think I'm a lesbian though
You can focus more tightly on your target because you have to like play like I play with the tips of my fingers
and like obviously I have nails there so like
That'll be fine actually
It's just like moving around and strafing might not be the best
Good because I I accidentally pressed the w key
Do I need to do how many times you have to do this?
This makes me miss uh, what's it called?
Hand cannons from destiny
Pressing all the keys wait, you're not that means you guys would be women so
I'm experiencing some resistance on my mouse paid my mouse paid my mouse paid it's because there's cat litter on it
Hunter naturally
No, I just I'm just saying I miss hand cannons
See I'm not fast though
Takes me a while to line up my shots. Oh
No, I don't want this though. Can I have a different gun?
My finger keeps slipping out
Okay, it's literally it's just this one I need to cut it's just my ring finger
You thought I was blowing smoke off the barrel like a cowboy my dad's a warlock main on destiny
Sorry, I'm just cutting my nail
There we go
Right no no yep, I'm gonna have to cut off my entire
I
Practice as much as you want then meet me at the gauntlet
Yeah, I'll be right there. Give me a fucking second bro. I'm trying to walk in
Thanks we do for games. What did I play? What do you mean? I played a lot of crucible and destiny if that's what you're asking
Face that yeah, my dad, uh, then he tried playing titan, but you didn't like it. So he like he prefers warlock
My dad usually will play like
What's it called
He'll play like
fast characters or like magical like long range characters
But he never actually could get the hang of the hunter that will
he
Yeah, I think he just like the medium speed of uh
A warlock
So cut my thumb
I actually I ripped my thumbnail. So that's why I was gonna cut these anyways because they're so long
I almost ripped my thumbnail off when I was opening boxes
Ow
My nail just shot me in the face
What the fuck did that go? Hello? I went down my shirt. I can't
I
I'm wearing the onesie. This isn't gonna work
Get it out
No, I'm not a nail gun. Um
Yeah, I was opening a box and I tore my nail bit my nail back, you know, I like looked at it and I was like
Ah
But it's fine like it was just bleeding a little bit
This is not
Nice, okay, I need a nail file to smooth these puppies down
Yeah, I know it hurt like a pitch. I tore my nail bed just a little bit. It went up a little bit. Oh, okay
I have one hand short and one hand long. Practice as much as you want. Then meet me at the gauntlet
But I don't like long nails are fine when I use a mouse. I'll cut those later
I
Anyways, I'm gonna pretend like you're doing my nails with this along
Oh my god, that would be such a good role play what the heck I do your nails
so
Tell me about you, you know your girlfriend. You got a girlfriend
Is she cute
You guys gonna have babies
You're getting married
Oh, you don't have a girlfriend
You want one?
I did
You did did you kill did you a killer? Why are you saying did?
She's a very cute bunny girl. I don't know what a bunny girl is sugar
But I don't is that like some sort of sex thing like
I don't have any chewing gum
So like
How big's your dick
Anyways, um, sorry I have to rest um
Your nail beds are really nice. They're cuticle just needs to be cut back a little bit
She wears the ears in bed interesting interesting
Yeah
I can't speak another language and that's stereotypical
Oh
My it really hurts to file down my thumb
But I need to beautiful my nails still look really good. They're just short now
You know your brother
I heard
Was one of those homophones. Is that true?
You know, I love the homophones
They're really nice people
69?
My god
This is more of a jersey than a than a boss an accent
Nice nice you
You
Cool
All right, I have my boba tea that has whole milk in it. So I'll probably fucking die later. That's fine
Like lewis or lois
We'll run the gauntlet
Peta, you know, yeah, brother's one of those homophones
I think bryan's a homophone. Do you think bryan thinks that?
Oh, yeah, this is much better. Oh, fuck. Yeah. Okay. Let's go
All right, you got a new gauntlet. Fuck this go XLR
Fuck it go over there
Okay, I turned off my monitor again, it's fine
Just kidding I unplugged it plug it back in
Don't worry. I can't see anything
No, no, what am I doing? Am I killing people?
I almost fell off
Why am I running 20? Oh, I thought I was running 22 miles an hour
Oh, they're not even shooting at me this is boring
What
What I want you to shoot over the shoulder
What the fuck hide his outline his head
I don't even know what I'm doing
Oh
Is there any other dudes that I miss? Oh wait, there's
Yeah
I think I killed him that I don't fucking know
Nice run see the results board on the wall. That's a regular
Because I just kept pausing
Look at the results board for more tips on how to improve. I see I didn't fucking notice there's two guys. I miss
I don't can I just play the game
I just want to play the game
How do I play the game run the gauntlet as much as you want that's done. I've got something special. I'm done
What the fuck oh, what why'd you teleport two inches? Yes
I'm ready to see what's next
I'm matt mercer
Let's play some dnd
What that one girl from trueblood who was also great at dnd by the way, she's pretty awesome
That actually makes me want to get into dnd
I'm not listening to what they're saying
But first we're gonna need a little more space
Whoa, that's my partner bt. He's a vanguard. Oh, yeah, you die spoiler
They're there
Oh
first Titan
I thought I could make him land right here. Whoa. No way
All right, right woman. Sounds like it's about to hit the fan. I'm pulling you out. All right
I don't remember this
Oh my god vr vr makes me fucking nauseous
Hold on
I need a
Sorry, I'm very particular about how my hands feel when I'm playing an fps
I need to clip one nail on my other hand because my pinky nail that's resting off of the
mouse keeps rubbing against my
Track pad not track pad mouse pad. It doesn't feel good
It's the tizium you own it. No, I don't have tizium
There we go, we'll make a pilot out of you yet rifleman. We're not today. Can I leave this place?
I'm just a lot to you some osa, you know, if I change my last day, I should change to that guy's name
My next
Character is
Latisa mosta
Last he's Latisa last timosa. I can't
I'm trying I've been trying but he keeps talking to me. I don't know what you want
I
Just played on regular mode
Very particular indeed
So, uh
You like jazz no, I'm not crack shut up shut your whole mouth
short
Shut it real quick
I threw my go xLR like halfway off my desk by the way
Like I started an hour ago and I've only just gone past the fucking tutorial
So
If there's a titanfall 3 I want to be an NPC in it just let me voice in the game, please
We are going down
Wait a second are we playing a
Game
Gonna run the brothel on an island
I don't know what that means that I caught a little pokemon where we dropping boys loot lake get me out of here
Wait, that's a different game sun sue fentons. I'm getting fent
Oh
Let me shoot things chaotic sounds of battle
All right, you guys ready to watch me suck
What oh, that's my teammate see
I can't tell who is who oh my god
Are you evil? No, you're assuming maybe it's red. Oh, yes red red
Oh cute
Well, it's hard to talk during this stuff
I was slowly
Crawling I saw our head
I'm gonna go this way. No, I'm gonna do my own thing. Wait, do you have a I like take the
Oh
She's locked in immediately tries to work her teammates you guys good. Let's go bros. I'm gonna read the chat
What is pokemon batman I'm stuck on a tree. Sorry. I'm a little bit blind
I almost shot my teammate again. Oh
Out jump scarer. Oh my god
Imagine just like rolls credits and I died there
That was a weird
I'll be fine. Don't worry about it. It's just a question. You should be okay when you wake up
It'll knock me out
All right, what the fuck help help
Sorry, I'm paralyzed so I can only just lay here. Oh, no
Lacrimosa, latrimo lastimosa
I just fucking died
Look out koopa. They're the apex legends
I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm a dead body. I'm a dead body. I'm a dead body
Would you rip off his fucking ear you animal?
We're in space you don't have to do that
Hope you like don't take my ear
Yes, I know he collects guys. I've played this before
A year ago, I don't remember a lot of it. So thank you for the reminder. Actually, I'm gonna shut the fuck up
It's him john apex
Oh, it's a puppy
I got that dog
That's a amazing character design for the fauna
BT
I'm coming BT. I can't sorry. I can only walk now. I can run. Hey, what's up, bro?
What the
Uh, you're not looking too hot brother
Oh
If I just stared at him and let him die
BT transfer authorization to new pilot what link
bruh
Bravo, bro
Seven two seven four
No
Latimosta my titan
Use my helmet in my junk kit
Okay, mr
Take care of him
I will
I'll take good care of the robot
But
I had all this time to bury you in stones by the way, and we're not in an active war zone or anything
Did I take off the helmet I must have had on before right?
It's rocked
Hi, sorry, I'm walking again, and I can only walk now. I can run when I get closer to you. Hey
What's up BT
I'm so sorry about rockamosa, but he's rocking
He's he's rock steady and be bopping in his grave right now. That's all I gotta say
Um
Do I do why am I why am I holding this like I'm a fucking gangster? Can I stop?
I want to crouch. I hold it sideways. I guess it doesn't make any sense
Dogs
All right, I'm waiting power low
Insufficient power such a great fucking voice actor and like voice edit for him
Huh power low puppy in the way
All right, uh
Power low. All right later sufficient power
I was jumped off work. I swear there was a dog. Oh, what are you doing?
Oh double jump offline stupid
Sorry
What was that? Is he on this? Why am I picking up a random helmet?
We're relocating to the IMC
Pilot need to find power cores for I am on low power. He turned into a fossil
Okay, girl. So if it likes you as much as I collect the most
What am I doing then jump? There we go
Uh, I don't have a double jump
Jumping status
Of interstellar
Sorry, Matthew McConaughey. All right. All right. All right
Nope, I didn't mean to jump
What where those voices coming from
Okay
Oh fuck no god damn it. I didn't mean to jump
Anyways
Oh my god, why am I so I'm getting ahead of myself am I stuck?
No, I'm not
Sorry boys
I uh
Woke up on the wrong side of the wall jumper today
No, no, no, no
I like I I don't know. I'm assuming I have a double jump and I I don't can I just die in the water
Let's go shake it to shake it off. Just shake it off. I shake it off. Uh, oh
Shake it off. I shake it off
Cause the I hate I thought this was lava
What why did I say e and then it says f I'm gonna sneak I'm gonna sneak I'm gonna sneak
Sorry, I'm busy
Wait
I'm shooting over your shoulder. I would be dead. This is an apex game
Do I need it? Okay
Don't worry about it
Oh a cloak you don't see this it's a dude over here though
What this is why I'm not gonna apex bro
Die, thank you
Uh, you know, I'm not good at ps games because I can't usually see people because I just suck at that for some reason
I
Push up brother, where is it?
I don't hold I just toggle it
Wait, can I
I
What
Oh, I don't know where to go
Oh
Wow, this is a support burst
Can I
Oh
No, I didn't mean to ride that
Sorry, I didn't know where I was going for a second dmr
Can I have two do I I'm assuming is it a sinuating that I haven't needed a dmr
I don't even see any dudes. Oh, let's take this
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I didn't read. Uh, I might die. Oh, oh, I didn't even take the gun I wanted
Now
I'm not that smart when I play FPS games. I will tell you that much
Why is it
Oh fucking finally. Oh, I did not let it matters
Oh, there we go
Oh
I should have just let him third party those
Get up
I didn't know there were so many there
Yes, I know dmr is a single shot
I
Swap my empty gun I do that. Oh, I'm fucking stupid
Hold on I just need to pick up a gun give me a second
I'm just gonna spray and pray for a second
Oh
Please
Oh my god, fucking bull
I told you I forget
I'm actually
Oh
Is that a dude? No, it's not
Uh, yeet you
Oh
Something behind me. Oh, yeah, who'd you come from?
She will remain in the hood until further notice indeed. Oh, what the fuck Rudy?
I don't have a lot of ammo. Uh, can I like peek around just to shoot at y'all or no
Oh my god, they have the high ground
Ouch
Oh to hack it
I don't really have a lot of ammo left
It's like a weird scout rifle
I can't I have to stay in one spot. I'm too I'm too mentally in equipped
How are you are you dead? Oh, no, I don't need a shotgun. Did I pick up ammo? Oh, I did
Ah
Yeah, what hurry I thought you were dead
Something in the game stream and thought it was Ira
Why are your fav youtubers who's playing timefall? Oh, who is it then?
Any ammo oh, what the frick y'all scared me
Anybody up there
Can I like take your gun? Oh, thank you
Um, oh, I'm like wait a second sometimes again, it's hard for me to tell directions and paths and games like I said
This is the YMCA missed
I'm getting dizzy
Yeah
Uh, oh, I remember last time I was here. I didn't know where to go in this portion. I was just so fucking confused
Um
Oh, this is making me dizzy
What the fuck am I doing? Do I crawl?
Please am I not supposed to go that way?
This is making me dizzy. This is making me so fucking dizzy and turn around. Oh ammo. Thanks
Wrong hole
To
The same thing happened to me last time, please let me in
How am I
All right, you're telling me I can't fall through this hole
The James Fallon has been said to take down ISP feature facility on the planet
And then I get turned around because I don't know where the fuck I'm going. Is this where I came from?
I don't know where the fuck I'm going
You were brave enough to join people believe
At least I got there faster a lot faster than last time. I'm telling you like fucking 30 minutes to find the right direction
Can you tell me upright? I'm never gonna know what you mean
I'm not gonna take a direction
So I'm eating a cookie
All hands the James Fallon has been said to take down ISP research facility on the planet hyphen
You are all here because you want to be part of something that matters. I got so dizzy in there
Poppy
Where am I while running
I
Start ghost runner this is just tell me where oh, this is saw me how to walk
That's funny. It's like this is how you do it
Eat I hope BT doesn't mind
Shoot him in the butt
Tighten up when are you gonna fucking do power low insufficient power here may put those in your booty cheek
Kind of cookie it's a s'mores
Power at two thirds data core re-initialized ocular system online
Adjusting focus. Hey, all right pilot. Yeah, fine
Why'd you call me pilot?
Wait, did you just call me pilot? Yes. The late captain. Yes gave you the provisional rank of acting pilot
Congratulations on your promotion
Why do you have to die? Wait, where's it? Oh, they're still there. Got it
Oh rock remosa
But a third battery will excite you
I will remain here
Until I am mobile I will assist you through your helmet radio when possible
I can't get up. What was that?
Pilot I advise against turning yourself over to the IMC. It wasn't planning on a BT
Don't worry, I'm not going anywhere. If I just ignored him
You recommend you move IMC salvage teams are not far away
I'm so fucking disrespectful
Um
Spray and pray ladies and gentlemen spray and pray
That's what I learned with the p90 on csgo
Yeah
Okay, oh somehow I made that
You think we can survive through this BT
We have no other options. We will have to improvise and attack if we wish to survive. Don't worry about it
How long did you serve with last time osa? Oh last time osa
What?
Oh, you must have been close. He's like I'm a robot. I don't have fucking feelings
It's awkward
I don't want I'm looking at this. All right, well they saw me
I couldn't scope in there
Ow I'm gonna die
Unless your suit has an emergency cloaking ability this can help you survive dangerous situations. Do you see me?
Oh, he could see me he could see me
Oh, what the fuck are you robot? I forgot to reload. Yeah
He's here, uh, my pronouns are fuck you
What where'd you go?
Instead
Die die punch your ass
Hey, you know what I'm just gonna come here. Come here. Come here. Come here
I forgot. Oh, I totally forgot about the fucking kicks the kicks. Oh, I'm just gonna
Oh
It's all it's not on hard so I should be fine
What is do I need I hate spitfire? I don't do I don't think I need those
Hello
Sorry, I'm scratching my nose. Which way do I go 26 meters? All right
Sir, I'm not interested in what you're selling
Is that you an advisor
I saw them
Sorry, I just want to keep kicking everybody
Oh, I accidentally like tap something
I'm wearing my hood and I don't mean to why are you gonna kill me and throw me into I'm gonna die. I'm gonna die
I need cover
Yeah, I am gonna use that right now
So I wonder my hat came on. Hello
I guess I can't fucking
Hello that's not working
Fuck you
Let's do so over there
Oh, I shot right over your shoulder, buddy. I'm not a good sniper
What is it
Why aren't you dying? All right, I guess that just doesn't work
Oh
Please hold
Thankfully like the AI sucks. So I like it's it's hard for me to die
Unless I like throw myself at a stupid situation like I've been often doing
Because I'm not good the AI is just bad
Oh, I didn't see I also bad vision. I didn't see them there
No, no, no, did I burp? I don't even know
Do not even recall
BT who is this voice?
I think I also got lost in here last time
Is anyone alive? I don't know you fucking tell me pilot. Does it look like anybody's alive?
Excuse me, but 90% of the lifeboats have been ejected. There is still hope
I think I recall that I have to jump up here
Oh my god, please
No
Am I stupid?
Okay, I'm stupid
Go the way I was going this clear bright fucking light
And then I had to oh fuck uh
Oh, yes, I was going up. I remember getting stuck there because I didn't realize I had to go fucking up
It's time to crawl into the little vent
Which is like the same size as that fucking hole
I wish I would stop holding
Oh
Hello, can you hear me?
Do I have a custom keyboard? Oh, no, I just have a black widow. Of course
I have a ducky one keyboard that I built. I forget. I think I had brown keys on it. I don't know brown switches
I
There it is
I'm so back bros
That was a fun little slip inside
Sussy number Bravo tango sussie number Bravo. Oh chassis. Let's use it sussie
My location has been compromised
Oh, yeah, it's crazy
Um, what do I do? Oh, I have to secure the area. Oh, this is awkward. Oh, I should have reloaded a really long time ago
Oh, I'm out of fucking ammo
Oh
Oh, bt. You're on your own bro. I'm sorry. I'm out of here
Um, give me a second. Give me a second. Give me a second
You're fucking why are you still alive?
Jesus
Yeah, let's complete the neural link immediately. Please install the final battery. Please insert your battery into me
Hello, hello
Sounds more like the blue. No, I'm not using a ducky keyboard right now
This is I don't even I can't even recall what switches are on this pilot
We must establish a neural link in order to proceed. Yeah, I generally don't know what
Please embark when ready
Oh, I'm getting in the fucking robot bro
Man a man just died in here for a second
Getting the fucking robot mad Mercer. Wait, do I have tattoos? What?
Why do I have like cyberpunk tattoos? Cyberpunk means Titanfall protocol one link to pilot
establishing neural link
I'm going ghosts
I'm entering the matrix neural link established
Rifleman jack kubernetes. You are now confirmed as acting pilot of bt 7274
Whoa protocol two
What you don't like tatted up guys. No, that's not a problem. Zoom special operation. I think tats are cool
I like tats
Pretty indifferent
I'm detecting incoming enemy forces. Yeah, I wish I could fucking see
protect the pilot
re-initializing critical systems
The vortex shield on line the vortex shield catches incoming rounds and missiles release the button to launch
I just got fucking obliterated
Please
Can I move?
Oh
Okay, that's great the warlocks you will achieve okay these kill them all
Yeah
Neuralink complete primary weapon control and motion link. Can I fucking move? I hate this
Yeah, let's go get absolutely right what they just disappeared pilot enemy titanfall detected
I just like stepping on people to be honest with you. Is that fucked up on me?
I just like stomping on people and I tighten and hearing them scream
Yeah, it's gonna kill a few bad guys still too bad. Yeah, I'm gonna kill a man who already killed dozens of men
All right, let's fuck me bro. Ah
Battery required
Oh, give me your fucking shit, bro
Stompy murder robots our mission of rendezvousing with major anderson until then you and I are on
Mr. Anderson
All right
Oh
Perfect little place to run with my little robot self
Why does that why does my hood keep coming up?
I'm not even pressing that number
It's one of my attacks like I don't know how you guys doing
Is this amazing for you
You're like, wow, she shit will continue to search for us our only chance of survival is to rendezvous with major anderson
60 clicks from our
Anderson
I'm on a road
What's up, bitch I'm here now mother fuckers
Yeah, that's BT eat my fucking
You guys love me even if I'm not
Yeah, give me your battery
Oh
Brother, who are you shooting? Oh my god, what was that?
Is there a guy just like hanging out here, let's
I'm confused
Oh
I'll do it on him that said
I
Did the burst corona when he was already fucking dying he's doing his best tie-in locked who
What
I am confused
Saying there's a tie. Oh, what the hell you'll be more fun when you take
I bet you'll be more fun when you're fucking at full
You're lucky that shit is there
I crouch. Oh, I can't
I can't reach me
Lieutenant Shaver that's a name
You're late. How dare
Let's go lieutenant
I think uh boss boy is up here. We got his name
Oh, I'm stepping on you motherfuckers
All forces move in come here come here. Come here. I'm stepping on you
Shoot me motherfucker shoot me. Oh what I hope you're paying attention violence
Hope I'm paying attention. What is that supposed to mean excessive damage warning warning
Excessive damage, I'm fine. Oh, I'm not fine
Why are you jumping I want to jump I don't really need the first core
I need a I need some batteries. I know there's one behind me. I think there's one closer over here. Yeah
Yeah
Can I crouch I can't reach those are you fucking shitting me right now
Go human do I just get out? Oh shit, I didn't know if I could get out at this point
If I are stopped I need to listen to some prodigy while I play this
I need to fire a stall
F1 tone I didn't mean to press E
Sorry
Somebody's in love
A human's concept of love requires aberration like how we started talking before devotion and respect
conclusion
I am 50 percent in love
Hey, yo BT you want to smash you can lock onto enemies and target them with tracking rockets
All right
All right, BT
Destroying
What
Oh, yeah, we're gonna do that
Where are you?
Oh my god, bro stop fucking
I'm running
Thank you. I'll take that. Thank you
Oh
I totally miss it's fine. Don't worry about it. He didn't he didn't notice the damn thing. Um
Is there a dude over here
Anybody else you must want to get fucking punched all along
Then I'll punch you
I'm stuck
You
Thank you
Oh fuck I can't punch you you two up high
Oh
Hip spray
Hostile pilot you're australian
You are indeed brother
Why do you fucking ninja stars
Oh fuck facility is blocked by a flow regulation gate. There should be a control interface nearby
Who all right
Engaged opening flow regulation gate. Hey, that's pretty stupid
Activating control room safety airlock procedures
Uh the safety airlock has sealed you in the control room. You must find another way out
We have no choice but to split up
Oh crazy, I'll find a way out. Don't you worry BT?
A nearby exit will most likely lead further. Yes. I know I can do executions
I was trying to do it behind him, but it didn't really work out. I just ended up kicking him instead
You got it BT you do the same copy that pilot. Oh, you're not dead
Oh, I just love shooting people in titanfall. I mean
Oh
Give me that caber wait. I have a flat line. Oh
I am such a that just just just if they offer me a gun in a game
Then I'm just assuming they want me to use it. Yeah, like right now
Oh, no scope. Fuck uh 360
You're good, you're fine you're fine, bro
That's for the it's for the clips bro, it's for the clips, of course
Oh, I weird I didn't know that okay ready ready ready ready ready guys ready ready ready 360 wait
You like that save that for the montage, baby
What we have here my IMC and militia friends cool is a failure to communicate
They hack you
Are you fucking nutting it sounds like it
Sorry, I totally missed that landing you should have died sooner
All right ready 360 no scope
Ready 360 no scope 360 no scope
Fuck 360 no scope
Where am I? Oh, okay, this isn't working out
Oh
Yeah, that sucks. All right, uh, let's work on a 360 no scope ready
All right, all right, all right, all right, all right 360 no scope
360 no scope
No scope no no
No
Oh
I'm sorry, I'm fucking around
Where am I? Hello. Oh
No scope no scope
Oh, did I kill him?
I just want a no scope
Oh fucking you empire
Empire that's not working
Oh, sorry, let me just get my health back
I got him. Yeah, you know, I'm pretty I'm pretty sick with it
Pretty sick with it brother
Just so you know, this is Kane's place you're welcome to stay as long as it takes
I missed you get punched for that
You get punched when I miss
Infantry we're trapped
Yeah, it's bad, so I'm just fucking around I'm sorry
And maybe I'm trying to think maybe I should have put on hard mode because I'm just doing stupid stuff
No, you don't
Friendly fire let's go
Damn it. I can't shoot you
What's up
It's me it's latimosa it's lakrimosa. It's rock timosa. Oh, he's dead. I should probably take their guns
Oh, that's pretty sick. Uh, you guys any better guns around here?
I don't really care about that
Actually, you know what?
I suck with that. Yeah, baby
No, fuck. Yeah, let's do that
Your face all right
Oh
Yeah
I didn't know it was a fucking horror game
It's like a horror game
Oh, I like that actually
I don't remember guns. Do you have anything? Sorry, I like I love looting bodies
Yes, I know I can hack them. I don't care. You don't have to tell me I know people are gonna say
Oh, what am I doing?
Oh, you're
So awkward, how do you guys get over here?
How are you still alive?
Uh, he just teleported for some reason. Maybe I should have kept the creeper
Let me just look at chat for a second
I'm gonna love Borderlands. Yeah, I am
Hello, Mr. Obama. Oh, what the fuck are you doing there? You scared me, bro
All right, uh, let's do a little
I can't get a bloody shot. It's an all-star
SMG, hey
Check your angles. Check your angles. Check your angles
Got a visual it's a pilot. It's a pilot
It's a pilot. Sorry
All right guys, come on down
Oh never mind
Oh, you motherfucker. I forgot you're a little bit more tankier. Give me a second
Do you have a gun?
Oh, I hate this fucking great. I hate laser-based or like plasma-based guns are my least favorite thing like a destiny. I fucking hate those ones
Where am I going queen?
What the fuck?
Well, I can't go down there so what the shabby
I know I'm supposed to go in this direction, but I'm not going about it the right way. There it is
I
Love the vaulting in this game. It's just so satisfying
Oh, you're gone. You're literally just disintegrated. Oh Jesus
Oh, okay. You know what? I'm a kind of a fan of the bloody mist. I'm not I'm not mad about the bloody mist
It's quite nice. It's just as satisfying as if I was kicking you myself
You know like it's a little bit
Highlight out of sight you were just looking at me
How can he hit me but I can't hit him who is shooting me? Oh
I don't know why I hit fired, but you know
Oh, are you spawning in I'd swear how did I walk past all of you?
Oh
Actually, I need a different gun. Excuse me. I would like that
Keeps up
Maybe they should get better maybe I should have played this one hard
Oh
Oh, you're gonna explode I'm gonna die if you explode near me. Yep, I couldn't back up
Left my spine out
What that's an interesting checkpoint
So I got word that there's some vanguard class tight
My double clip it click is fucking yeah, because it's making me scope in and not what I don't want to
I need to get away from you
Oh
Oh my god
I I threw an aid why isn't affecting you thank you
Oh, give me that gun back that was pretty fun
I don't see anything. Oh what the fuck is that I missed I can't hear what I'm saying
I shot and then I missed and then I shot and then I missed and then I shot
And then what do you guys do the fucking corner fucking jerking off? Jesus
In your fire stop
I like to toggle aim, I don't like hold aim. I prefer to toggle aim. I don't know
Oh
Why do I feel really short am I crouching no are you fighting the British perhaps
Oh wait, you guys are just working on stuff. I'm so sorry. I just killed you. You didn't even need to be killed
It's killed or be killed
Oh, cute flowy. Uh, where are you? Where the fuck am I? Oh
Sorry, I don't trust you I'll kill you as well
This is what my period looks like when I'm having a bad day. Oh, what the fuck
Oh
Oh, no, you're just a robot. I'm not gonna hurt you. You're just smiting your own business
You got a battery in your booty cheek. Did you know that?
Great sounds good
Prepare yourself pilot. Oh, I'm so ready. I just want to kill people in minecraft
Uh and Titanfall minecraft and minecraft Titanfall
Bitch
Hi
Your helmet provided me with a live feed of your actions
I was killed you too
The controls to deactivate the sludge flower in the next chamber
Alternate ending where if you don't kill any of the robots you get like the true ending
I am see security forces
I guess that's why they pay me the big bucks. You want something done, right? You do it yourself
All right scrubs enough's enough. I'm coming down
Oh daddy's coming down stairs. Why didn't you die because I shot your fucking ankles?
Oh, you're so lucky
He's behind me
No
Fuck I love gore. Sorry
Sorry, um mental illness
Die die die die. Where'd your body go? Oh, that's okay
Uh, I guess it's assuming I won't want me to use this craver
What? Oh
I hear dudes are they right below me?
Where are you? Yeah, but where are you? I hear you. Oh
Your voice line change those are more of you
All right, we will need to deactivate the sludge flows in order to regroup
I have marked the controls on your hood in my hood
I have marked the controls on your hood
It was my mercy impression
Oh, no
Oh, fuck. No, I hate those things
Oh
I hate those things so fucking bad
Oh, fuck, where's the grenade launcher?
Oh
I hate those things
I
No, why do I have
The sludge falls contain a high concentration of heavy metals they are interfering with my targeting systems
I need a better fucking gun
But everybody's gone kind of fucked myself
Trying to see if I can have them explode on each other
Of course, it's a fucking shotgun it doesn't have range, but I don't have a choice
Thank you
Fuck is wrong me
Stop the sludge falls contain a high concentration of heavy metals they are interfering with my target. Oh, bitch
Just fucking shoot bro. Just shoot
Blind firing into my pilot's combat zone would be a violation of protocol three
Oh
No
I'm gonna kill you. Oh
Can I
Fuck me fuck me fuck me fuck me fuck
Oh
I'm dead. Hi
Bye, this is why we don't update. No, this is just fucking. I'm just bad
This is
What the fuck?
Uh, uh, I'm stuck
Oh, I can't
I can't move. Oh, okay. Now I can for some reason
I
Fine
Rain up this is not the time this is not the time to go on my lap
Is any of you rain up this is not the time you're stepping on my headphones. Oh my god
Oh
Can I have your gun? Oh my god, reina get off of me. I'm so sorry reina, but you cannot do this to me
She's not emotional support
Oh, I'm gonna die. Why does this spawn me right there so I have low health. I don't
Know
I'm it's because I'm not locking in
Where the fucking
Oh
No, if it was hard, I still could have done this
No, probably not actually look at my fucking game get away from
Actually
I
What
Oh
Stop
Oh my god
Oh
Yeah, keep moving in the places that oh
Visual contact reestablished with pilot commencing supporting fire danger close in you
Can you
Can you kill them for me?
Are they all this fucking disappear to assist you
That's so weird you just I know I do survive
Oh, I guess I have to kill you guys
You guys hide it in here. That's pretty smart. That was a difficult panel. You handled yourself. Well, sometimes the AI talks to itself in different voices
I have identified an exit on this side
this way
Rejoined how do I do I just
Oh, wow perfectly
How convenient that there are no wires right there
Controls transferred to pilot
Protocol to uphold the mission our orders are to resume special operation 217
Tunnel Dennis
Look at all these dead people
The
I think he's fine with an srs vanguard class titan
Well now we're talking
Let's get this party started scrub
Oh
Oh, I forgot I forgot
I
Call me a fucking
Can this spawn more batteries, please?
Are you
Do you die?
What the fuck was that that was very anticlimactic anyways
Cain's helmet radio is still intact. We should retrieve it. Oh, okay. Well, sorry. Let me walk back
Am I okay? Well, I just I would I when I play FPS is I'm just I'm a different person
I'm a I'm a different girly pop
I
My favorite titan, I don't remember
Ask me questions. I don't remember the answers to
Can I have your hat? I mean your hat can I have your helmet? It's kind of cooler than mine, but you probably smell bad
I
Sick, thanks. Uh, anyways later scrub get fucked. Uh, yeah. Oh never mind
BT pick me up
BT uppies
BT
The ability to decrypt enemy communications has a strong history and I turn into I turn toxic to our advantage
I don't know in order to survive why my hat thing keeps popping up. I'm not pressing seven
I'm trying to see what I'm pressing
Wait, what was it?
Something's linked. Oh, it's fucking tab
Why is tab a link to that hold on
It's my locked-in hood
I don't know why tab is
Actually, I can't get rid of it because it's part of the outfit
Um, and not part of my model, you know, and I guess I'm just gonna be tabbed in hold on. Let me just
My head's kind of peeking out hold on
Where'd my mole go?
Why is my face just like help? You know what? Sorry
I need to lock in ladies and gentlemen where the gloves are coming off where fuck fuck this
Fuck that the gloves are coming off
Oh, my thumb really hurts
I wish I had a gaming outfit. I need like I need like a sweaty neat gamer outfit when I play FPS is
That would be very nice
Now that was the ultimate life now because now I can turn out my physics because I realize my face looks like it's really like not
um
Because my physics are down
Now you can see how my face moves around and now I can obviously like emo a little bit better
And my mouth tracking is a lot better and you can see I'm a lot more movable
I have to turn it down when I wear outfits, but now I don't have to do that
Let's go fucking. Let's let's fucking
We're locked in baby
Hold on. I want my titties to show because everybody likes that everybody wants to see a little bit of tittie, don't they?
I was nerfed. I was nerfed the whole time
This is great. Hold on. My back hurts. I'm gonna do ventriloquist for a second
Sorry, I'm trying to fart. It's not really working out for me
Oh
All right, I'm ready
How's fear doing let's check. Oh my god, Reyna scared me. She's right. It's Reyna's just staring at me right next to me
See ya
Fia, are you feeling good? Fia
wake up
Boomi looks like a fucking
Dork he's laying on a towel. He's laying. I don't know. He's sleeping on the towel that I used to feed Fia that so that food doesn't go anywhere
Now he's getting up because I'm talking shit. Fia is napping
She didn't raise her head
No, Reyna
It's not snuggle time. I'm so sorry
You can't keep popping up on my desk
I almost rolled over your tail
Please
I'll give you a pet, but you know you can't come up here
She's like if pet why can't I not join you?
Did you hear her?
Okay, okay, rena fine fine. You can come up here. Come on
Fine
Go on
All right
Because you asked so nicely
What's up? Hello, mama. Hello. All right. All right. How are you doing?
Okay
Great now my allergy is going to kick in because of you because I'm shoving my face into your fur and I need to brush you
Reyna, I can't hold you in my arms
late late at night
I can't like you're gonna be on my lap, but I can't hold you in my arms
She wanted the hood to stay
I'm sure like I'll get like an all outfit at some point. That's kind of like normal and cutesy
But like still like
me
Reena you wish squishy tummy
No, don't leave. You can't just leave after you came over here. Anyways, let's do this thing
Press space to continue
It's like a t-shirt. Yeah, just a t-shirt honestly me
To the rendezvous point. Hi. I recommend we proceed. Hi rena. Can you say hi rena?
Can you say hi rena squeak squeak rena?
She just headbutting my desk. Hi. Why do you look like that? Why are you drooling?
Hey
You're gonna say something
Usually you're talkative. I'm surprised you're not saying nothing right now
I
She's licking my arm. Um, what gamer pose are you doing now?
Are leaning into the screen. No, I'm leaning back with my cat on my lap licking my arm
Sitting up straight submitting requests for an oversized video, but
Well, I could just I can you know what I can do. I can do this for you
Where the fuck
You say oversized hoodie
I can just smack this on it'll just go crazy the entire time
You know
And it's has it's white but uh
Why is it shaking like that? Hold on. Let me make the neck a different color
I'm I'm I stole shibini's hoodie
Reena why the fuck did she just tweak out for us?
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna guess looking at
I know it's in the f's can't remember it's f7 something
Sure, that's fine. Okay, okay, let's add it to the fingies
Other fingy
Sick
Oh, what the fuck did I just open? Hello?
Do I hate I hate Microsoft sometimes. Okay
Uh
My neck is darker cuz shadow
But don't worry about it
Shadow the hedgehog
There you go. See no, uh
See now, I got my over hot oversized hoodie
And I'm ready to rumble, you know, I'm ready to I'm ready to tango
If you as you can see
What do you think
Dude does this work for you?
Looks like a gay where to be we're gay. Oh, do you want me to keep it on you want me to take it off?
You
Sorry I'm playing with my eyes
Oh
Looks like I suck at cardboard cutouts of my model
He's got real epee all of a sudden we out
Sick now it's my turn. Oh, I forgot that space is sprint
Oh, what is this place it looks like an apex map
What are we doing here bt we must proceed through this facility and continue to the rendezvous point with major anderson
Scorch you think that we would take it from kane, but
This is ash. I'm a playable character
This is ash go ahead
Ash out
This is ash go ahead. Hold on. I need to like add a little bit. This is ash go ahead
No, that sounds stupid. I wish I could turn down the morph a little bit. This is ash go ahead
Yeah, it kind of worked
I'm gonna take a kill that pilot if it's the last thing I do
Oh
Anyways
Should I keep it? Yeah, I'm gonna keep this on when I'm in bt. Do I go down here? I don't think I do. Do I?
Pilot let us commence
Proceeding forward
We're seeing forward
Someone is manufacturing trees
Who is manufacturing trees? Where are these trees coming from? What the actual fuck?
I
Let's brace yourself and prepare for snowshoeing wait
Wow, oh my god, hello
It sounds like fred
Sorry, um
Can I get rid of the echo and the reverb? Okay, that sounds a little bit better
Hey, it's fred
Okay, anyways, uh as we were
Can you hear what I'm saying?
Sheepie as the wally. I'm sheepie
Oh sweet people they fucking run over come here motherfuckers come here
Oh, yeah, baby. Yeah. Oh, it's gonna step on you come here
Wish wish wish wish wish wish wish wish wish wish wish wish wish wish wish wish wish wish wish wish
Oh, I'm so heavy. Oh, you can't? Oh giant sheepie. Oh the fuck did you go you can't run from me?
Motherfucker
Motherfucker. I'm
Come here
Come on you bitches. Oh, yes
You shut ah that feels so good
Oh, hey. Oh, I almost missed you. Why are there cars here?
Oh, don't mind me.
Oh, look, the squish noise is very satisfying.
Um...
I- Oh, come here.
Stop running!
Why would you run? There's no need for you to run.
I don't even need to shoot my weapon. Don't step on you motherfuckers.
Oh, come here.
That sucks.
Where are you bitches coming from?
Oh, that's good.
All righty, let's go.
I'm so sorry.
I think he's dead. I can't really tell.
I really have to aim.
Oh, I'm gonna die.
Oh, you're looking a little bit too far.
Oh, wait, did I hit you?
Oh, yeah, I did.
Anybody? Come on.
I want to punch someone like up close.
Oh, nice.
This will hurt me, won't it?
No.
No? Okay.
Oh, come on.
I'm gonna give you some of the punch.
Oh, yes, come here.
Come here, come here.
I'm not- I'm just gonna-
Oh, yeah, come on.
Oh, don't run.
It's not cute.
Oh.
Oh, hey, hi, hi.
Oh, my God.
That's not as bad as mine,
because the robots fucked you.
All right.
I know there's another Titan.
Where the fuck did he go?
Oh.
Hi.
Titan, what?
Oh, what the fuck?
Jesus.
What's the matter?
I don't know.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, you shouldn't have been there.
Okay.
Sorry.
Come here, motherfucker.
I actually don't like the forge build
to be real with you.
What the fuck is that?
I don't even know what this is doing.
All right, cool.
Is there a Titan half on fire?
Oh!
I'm so fucking stupid.
Titan half on fire?
There you go.
That's better.
I like that low, actually.
BT, why are you suddenly British?
Don't fucking worry about it.
Oi, oi, oi, oi.
Oh, man.
Is that your son?
What is that?
Oh, there's a battery.
Oh, there's another one.
You did my pressing half instead of G.
No, come over here, motherfucker.
Come here.
Session on fire.
Oh.
My apples.
You've got my attention.
I can't even a shot.
I see you catch this.
No.
What the thing for?
Oh.
All right.
Oh, honey.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, we backed the fuck up.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
These are like weaker.
Let me just.
Let me just say my best.
All right.
And then I do a little.
That works.
Oh, my God.
Not good with this one to be honest.
Playing full activate.
Wow.
It's off air.
Yeah, sure.
All right.
All right, BT.
Let's go.
Bitch.
I see you.
Where are you?
Come here.
Punch, punch, punch, punch.
Don't hide.
It only makes it harder for you.
I'm scratching my armpit.
Brute rocket launcher.
Let's try it.
Although I do like Scorch for crowd control.
Offers a shortcut through the facility.
Check your heart for the control panel.
Attemptation to throw myself off was very great there.
I don't even know if you guys can understand me.
Hello.
I wish I could show you guys arena is sitting on me right now
and is coming in one side.
Hello, guys.
How can I help you?
Hello.
Hello to you guys.
how Rena is sitting on me right now it is quite abusing oh sorry I was adjusting
myself in my chair that was kind of rude of you Mozambique here Mozambique
here Mozambique here Mozambique Mozambique here no all right don't be
yeah your squad's down sorry what I swear I saw somebody like cloak and run
am I supposed to go with you this is not a we'll meet up later thing I'm coming
I wonder if I just let him like get taken
if I didn't do anything
Rena why are you laying like she's laying like a baby hi where are you going
why are you sitting like a woman you sitting like a woman
Rena I'm gonna use you as an armrest sorry I'm kissing my cat my ass hurts I need a
butter sea cushion Rena I don't want to have to use you as what are you smelling
what are you licking you're such a little fluffy blob on my lap
Rena is a baby yeah she's an elderly bit Rena I can't she's like right where I put my wrist
okay um ma'am you have to make a decision here do you want to be you oh all right well Rena has
put both of her front paws on my wrist that I'm using to walk around uh so I'm playing with weights
on right now she's she's holding me back this is actually quite cute she's literally just like
she's sitting on my lap her back paws are in my lap but her front paws are just on my arm
madam is stinky what do you mean
right this thing it's time for a short snack break she'll probably get some water
but because she's on me I'm not good when she leaves look I'll go get some water
yeah hey you need to clean your face lady
was last shower I showered today you fuckers I had to go out and do stuff so I showered
I didn't shave my armpits though I haven't shaved my armpits almost like a month now it's kind of weird
alright it's like I haven't gone without shaving for this long and it's the weirdest experience
because like I also feel weird because my hair stopped growing and I'm like oh okay
but it's not like long just there and I also don't sweat as much because of that and it's very
it's just very I'm like is this what guys go through all the time I don't know
no shower is bad yeah but getting a yeast infection is worse sweetheart
hello okay I'm taking this damn fucking hoodie off
do you get those a lot no I don't get those a lot
do you get those no because I'm clean do you get those a lot
oh my god I shaved my armpits the fuck has been reduced almost nothing oh so you you're a guy and
you shaved your armpits and you're fine it's like I I think I sweat more like I don't stink but like
I sweat more with my armpit shape aren't they self-cleaning yes but it doesn't mean you like
you can't do a little water in there like keep in mind discharge exists and if it's just sitting in
your underwear you're gonna have some problems and that's when you start smelling like fish
this guy sweat different a girl sweat that's a great question I don't know
yeah we still need to clean our coaches like what it's called an infection for a reason
I got the Asian gene of no body odor was that a thing I've never heard of that
but
I just been told I've been told by um my friends that I like when I sweat I don't smell bad I
like I guess I have good pheromones my hair also just smells good all the time I smell like candy
when I was hugging my parents goodbye they both smelled my hair and I'm like what is wrong with
you guys and they're just like you just smell good and I'm like stop stop I'm not a baby you
can't just smell my head I'm your grown grown child I'm your grown daughter
daughter
can I mail you guys my scent as a donor on a one
I don't know looks like Raina is praying
my butt hurts
I need assistance looks like the automated security in this place has picked up a tight
how are you not dead oh I forgot how to play for sake because I'm leaning forward my perspective
has changed I was leaning forward and I was locked in uh yeah you're behind me
all right I'm just gonna punch you
I'm a bit confused that I'm gonna blame it on Raina because she's like in my arm and I need to lean
back okay I think I'm good now pilot I need assistance don't you want my headphones Raina
security in this place has picked up a tight that's what we're up
surprise bitch
are you still a lot do you guys take okay looks like these dudes need a little bit more they're
like we're going up in level actually
because I'm like why is it taking forever to kill you
if I was a world war two they'd call me spitfire
sorry I love that song by the prodigy
if I was a world war two they'd call me
fired
because you know that I can
oh this is where you let me go
oh
all along I'm getting too cocky there
if you read me I'm being taken to this facility substation
who's that I was at a helmet do I need that
am I supposed to be collecting these things
I don't care much for that at all
and let's just jump into the void
all right let me uh back up
oh
oh god I fucking love wall running bro that's what I if destiny had wall running I would have
had a great time I only played destiny to fill a void of titanfall being like essentially canceled
you're fine
where the fuck am I supposed actually I'm gonna have you tell me where to go there bud
oh okay I looked a lot farther than it actually was I suppose
devotion I kind of want to throw yeah let's throw let's throw like some stars at them oh my god
hello
what the fuck am I stuck on oh into the butthole is this heron's butthole when I'm done with it
I can't see what oh my god Jesus fuck them maybe so does he
I don't see why we need that
oh I hate this area I have a vanguard class titan what would you like me to do with it
I want you to suck my peepee ash what am I supposed to go
this facility was built to kill okay I'm sure I could take advantage of that fact
if I have to ash that place is not your bloody playground I'm not paying you to be clever
I'm not playing paying you to be clever
pilot I'm being taken down in the subway line there may be a common exit I recommend you follow
the flow of the platforms
watch for crushing hazards on the assembly line
oh my god what the fuck are you wearing bro cosplaying is a fucking
I need a gun actually I have one of those
oh gross no I don't want this
I don't want to spit fire
oh this gun's right here
I didn't mean to pick that up
yippie oh no wait it's fine
I missed yeah I'm about to say scout rifle thank you don't worry about it
don't worry about it don't worry about it don't worry about it
why do I have a fucking craver out the hell is wrong with me
I don't like semi-auto in this type of game but oh I'm fucking stupid
why did I
like my r2d2 scheme
all right let's actually time this fucking correctly instead of just jumping off
I got a dumb ass oh my god or falling off like a dumb ass
glass he's on the platform oh I forgot it's not auto
I can't break that
fuck off
it's our guns over there
another dude oh
I'm 11 what is this what is this oh you're still alive
fucked I'll give that oh why my shit why my shit I just shot you in the dick
get shot in the other fucking dick
what I just automatically wrapped around that pole
like how no I'm gonna stop I'm just not gonna say nothing
all right yeah move this grass over please oh
thank you
thank you god what Jesus fuck
oh
lots of robots not really gonna do a lot for me oh I have the craver you ever got
okay
sorry
I thought it was god
oh
what are you doing why is the AI facing that way
360 no scope
wait let me just
oh come on I wanted to be cute there and do like a little like peak shot like it was cs
oh I should probably reload that
yeah 360 360 oh you want you want 360 let's do this
oh
ready 360 oh I missed
wait where are you oh oh come on ready 360
oh what fuck off
I'm almost at one bullet
oh I literally missed
oh that's funny
oh call of duty for this aliens
thank you
check the point check the point
there we go
this way it doesn't go anywhere
it's not I didn't mean to throw that
um that's where I came from
I hear something fucking opening oh this way there we go all right well I can wait I can wait
if you like Halo you probably like Titanfall guys
am I supposed to wall run
where this fucking even come from
hi I'm being taken through an area stocked with prefabricated structures we are not far
hey you know they look like they're trying to build affordable housing so
what the hell are they building here BT
unknown but I doubt the IMC are mass producing homes
maybe they are you don't know that look at this this is like the perfectly good couch
look it you have some more couches over there
this is great
am I supposed to do something oh it's a bookshelf oh sick look it
look they're building a house right around me hey how's it going bro
oh you can't do anything
oh you're just a little guy can I take your booty battery
I don't know why it's not letting me scope in oh no you motherfucker no you motherfucker
I can't
how are you not dead who are you shooting at
you
let's take a breather
this is a case because I haven't been able to pick up any Kraber ammo
I'm just gonna
go
it's crack
check appointment check appointment
oh my god
they did
how are you guys not dead
I'm out of bullets
there was another dude did he run backwards
he must have, there must be that guy
he am over here
ow
stop it's not very cash money of you there's another one of you
cool
no I don't want that give it back
what you got
did you guys all fucking spitfires what's what's what is this
what is this
Mozambique here Mozambique here Mozambique here guys there's a Mozambique here
there's a Mozambique
no you don't want it already then
later oh wait no I don't think I got I think I got it off here I think this is my stop
I can't tell where I've already come from to be honest with you
okay I came from here yep because I hopped on this thingy all right I just went in a circle
have you played any half-life game no my dad has though
I didn't look up there I didn't
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna go I don't really care
you don't need to fight them again
you spin me high around baby high around
oh hold on sorry give me a second for fellas
ow I can never tell
where what the fuck is there's a robot I know it is I just don't see him is he up top
oh yeah they're fucking up top
can I get a hoia bitch are you fucking serious
I'm a cosy before I can kill him
maybe it's a cuckoo I can't get over there
yeah
no put me over here that's pretty neat
oh but I can't hit him at all just waste of bullets there
can I have your gun you don't even have a mozi and beak that's why you fucking died bro
oh it's you
a bitch
try and read them you're having a good time there's a bookshelf in the way
and I shot and then I missed and I shot and then where the fuck is this robot gonna jump down from
there you are
all right I presume I go over here actually because they have it
where'd those ticks go do they all blow up together that's fine
oh I didn't even see you awkward
whoa whoa where am I going shot you in the fucking oh you're my friend now
wait you're not my friend
oh my I wasn't what the fuck was a hitbox he swung and it was far away
when's a hell divers club I sucked at hell divers I played with a couple of people on my
PL um not on my PL like as my PL I mean like before I left um and I was not good at it at all
I was just carried by one of Madara Khan's mods the entire time
she was pretty neat though so was uh I think I was also with something
thank you
three bullets to my name can I please
why am I shit with the scout rifle what the fuck
what no I don't actually want that
it's not as satisfying
there's something I like what is this oh shit oh I remember this oh yeah I remember this gun
oh you're so lucky peak bitch peak
anyways
oh so now what
I gotta somehow get over there
okay yeah we take that
all right now I know what they want me to do
oh hello
how
okay um hold on let me just sorry isn't as linear as you think it would be
it's a little bit confusing now I have to wait oh this is why they gave me this
why are you still alive
here we are
all right yippie I want to be on here take me on the stairs what oh that was gonna throw me off
all right reload
let's go
can I have a fucking mozen no I want them damn Mozambique oh no I can't stop crouching stop
fucking crouching
you're shooting me oh
oh what the fuck oh
Robert
oh
that gun that I can use
no thank you
I'm shooting over you thought you'd get up a lot faster, but at least you can't hit me
as your fucking idiot oh but damn on the other hand
all righty I think it ricocheted off of his shield and killed me
Hi Mari! Mari's good at valorant
What the fuck is going on I see you bitch
off the platform I love just slipping and sliding everywhere
all dead there was a bunch of devotions all right where do I go next
thanks over here making me fucking dizzy bro Mari's the goat at Val absolute
go pilot pilot I'm dead I'm fine I'm getting lost more than anything
motion sickness my favorite they're finished the game yeah go finish it
click off right now and play alongside me my booty cheeks are let me adjust I'm
about to go sideways aren't I no I'm scared
oh ash I'm gonna fuck your robo cheeks I'm going to clap those robo cheeks I'm
gonna watch so much 3d porn in you later ash you are going to get absolutely
smashed oh fuck fuck fuck don't worry about it
waiting to clip me when something dumb happens like that that's suffice
oh fuck am I supposed to jump off I'm dizzy where do I go try my best BT it's
a little bit dilapidating that's not a word it's a little bit confusing it's
making me sick yeah I hate this so much oh my god I'm gonna turn my head sideways
my mind is like not having a good time
I'm not where I'm supposed to go just compobulating thank you
where am I supposed to go
what the shivity oh fuck I suppose to do that the fuck am I supposed to go time to
the top fuck your mom give me give me the
time to the how am I supposed to fuck oh my god I'm losing my mind I'm assuming
I go over here oh my god I'm gonna die can you like bring me there they literally
give you this so you can plot out of course the dome what do you start ghost
runner I don't need no ghost runner I am the ghost runner call me fucking ghost
busters away bust my nuts into ass ashes ass how about that
anyways sorry I'm getting so talk I'm so sorry
yippie I just fucking climbed a wall you think that's impressive my strap is
more impressive I would love to accept there's none hit your ride I will you
now ask will you will you
trip I know like I'm gonna be playing portal at some point with someone for a
collab not gonna say who well you watch them a lot if you watch me watch them
it's a gen mate and I know I'm gonna be puking the entire fucking time all right
come on ho
probably I want to be a surprise but oh my god I'm in apex just making me dizzy
as well Jesus this fucking terrible low res mountains are free what the fuck
turn around there's a building loading scenario one two seven should I play apex
after this and cry
it just flashes me just like pegging her awesome or what's our hot dude I suck
off BT what who said that who hello it's fucking ghost in my house I swear to
god delivering militia test subjects cool space
you shouldn't rely on me lettuce I am a rabbit this isn't a good gun for this
but this might be a little bit better no I'm jacking off BT leave me alone
I realize I forgot I didn't answer him he probably thinks I'm dead
oh is he gonna kill them all well they're dead I don't really know you want me to do
yeah they're they literally just got wiped so now he's gonna aggro me
the houses contain web and caches I saw them being loaded on the assembly line
can I fucking get a test sonar I don't my ears itchy hold on give me give me just
a second it's busy scratching my ear normal human being and you had to go
can I oh hello
how strange I'm built different bitch
objective destroy the militia pilot how copy over so they copy sucks that they
killed all my dudes because I had saved them all right I guess the spit fires
nice you just sent me two more dudes to kill you already said that you just
repeating yourself at this point can I please get let me back the fuck up Jesus
Christ the thing I just spit fire I really want to listen to that song now
as you know I thought I killed you I can't reload animation reloading takes
forever for this oh you die can I get like different frags
I have detected an opening in the outer wall you should get out of there while you can
oh we're gonna suck my little cop oh my god it's ghost
sorry I'm sucking boba okay I suck too hard it's fine hi Reno what are you doing with
your hand hello my pronouns are she be sorry I got a couple
of toys myself you only want to share you want to like train scuttle
oh I forgot they made them I forgot about that very alien versus predatory oh don't
fall off motherfucker pilot I do not know what you did a series of explosions just
I have broken free I have broken free what break it free sorry you're fine what's
happening great go set it up nope I'm close I'm so close I'm too close to
everybody I'm gonna die oh oh that actually worked where am I supposed to
fucking go am I gonna make it oh okay
BT I'm coming BT I'm already fucking inside of you
oh my god Jesus I just step on you I don't think so I think you're a bit tougher than
yeah grown in I wish I could change my fucking Ludo long can I oh neat you know I'll do
scorch let's fuck it fuck it let's do it am I doing I'm pressing the wrong button that's
what I'm doing I'm trying to press G what are you doing bro that went outside the map
sort of I gotta go later hello can you get down here
get down here oh what the fuck was that why just stick to me I don't like that can you
get down here all right am I supposed to shoot him from here okay I'm just gonna
change my loadout then like why the fuck what I have scorch on okay Rena Rena is leaving
I read I'm thinking all right let's do this
flight core ready
I think I would win that one yeah this is terrifying
why are you like already like half dead almost I can't walk on you guys it's too bad ooh the
music push push push yep yep yep yo why should you run it in like that I you don't
really have much to work with but I'll I'll find a way I'm just gonna strafe you a lot
oh damn she's about to kill me all right it's her her her her she she take a look it's me me
let us begin actually I would think I would prefer tonight fucking move
because she has to reload I can't see I can't see
she's gonna kill me I need a battery
I'm low-health if she regenerates health I'm pretty sure yeah she's shield and I don't regenerate shield
for sure
excessive damage warning warning
Are you serious bro, are you serious? Okay, I'm gonna
Fucking hit there
Oh
What are you talking about?
Kind of a save that cuz I can just my last one
It's time I go get it
Oh
How are you not dead yet
Shouldn't have taken that oh my god
I
Think
She's a robot. Why did it pull out and blood gushed everywhere pilot the security locked up. She's the apper like me. I
recommend we leave sorry just fucking destroyed her
That shouldn't have that shouldn't have taken three tries. I should have taken like one
We should take no further shortcuts
No fucking shit, bro. Oh, I know my girlfriend
Extra chunky red robot oil here
I'm gonna get some wah wah
Well, we started to
You're getting chunky
Why
Oh
Getting chonk for the winter
I
Glad robots are programmed to scream in fear
Now I can use a sword
Ronan class is pretty cool. No, I pretty cool and he's bulking
Boomi does not need to bulk
I
Eat this now
All this locking in has taken a lot out of me
I
Co-chat froze like a century ago booming go away
You cannot have my snacks
You
Again Gio Titanfall 2
By completing in one stream
Yeah, isn't it like four hours or something six hours I can do that one stream
I can't give him a little it's a cookie. He will die
Anonymous tipped four dollars and 20 cents. I wanted to thank you for showing me with chocolate. I just 100% edit
Yeah, I don't think there's a lot after this he's starving no
No, no to die
Need like another pillow for my back. Oh
His chocolate bad for cat. Did you not know that? Did you not know that chocolate is bad for cats?
That is extremely concerning
How my thumb hurts so bad
I
Was extremely concerning
You know my greenie. He has greenies. I am a greenie yesterday
And he another pillow
Oh
Let's do this. Oh, I am triple triple pillowing it up
I can't sit. Oh my god, I almost fell over. Oh, that's some good stuff, buddy
Madam he hungers
Did you know if you give your mouse a cookie?
I want some milk to go with it. Really? Did not know this
Yeah, that's and also grapes grapes are very poisonous to dogs as well people don't know that
Emerald I have my my my catpaw pillow that I'm sitting on which has I think just I've had it for a couple of years
and it's just like flattened now for my fucking fat ass and um, I just got my
Orthopedic pillow that I use for my neck
for my back
Just like that. What is I think I'm wearing my headphones wrong
There we go
Am I
And then I have another pillow for my head so I can sit up
Their punch kit big and they fly into the sky like a balloon
The thing is I wish I could put my feet up
But I can't because there's just a wall and my legs are long
If I was like four feet tall that'd be perfect
Major Anderson
Don't get fucking captured bro. I will avoid all shortcuts. Oh, I forgot about this where I fucking like
Where I go like fucking that's so raven into the past right over the fuck
Hey, am I shorter than you?
Oh
What just happened there are distortions throughout this facility and they appear to be causing a rift
Okay
No, well, this is awkward. So where do I go? Oh, there's a fucking hole in the wall. That's that's of course where I go
This looks like a like one of the dudes is from Elden ring one of the aristocrats
No, not the aristocrats just like
There we go
It fucking excuse me
Why do I see
Is that bt
Why does it say show bt over there, but it's not true
What is this place? Where am I? Oh, do I jump out? Oh, okay
This looks like a destiny. Can I have a better gun?
Strange I'm picking up traces of my own data signature within this area
This must be affecting my scans. He's dead
A lot of people are dead here. None of these remains. Smash the genetic profile of major Anderson. He'll still be alive
Can I recommend you check the main lobby perception? I would accompany you, but unfortunately my chassis will not fit
My chassis
Oh lucky you
I detect sarcasm
Oh
Not a funny crowd fucking mile away
uh
Oh, how's the
don't
Quite understand how that happened to you, but
She's dead
Could I
Oh
I can't see their face at all. Oh his I thought it was a girl that was talking before
Okay
Gorgeous
I'm right here here
Here take it. Oh fuck. I didn't mean to do that here
Here
What the hell
Command of special operation 217
You know
Congratulations on your field promotion while in kubernetes. Oh my god
Anderson's mission briefing from commander sarah brings a polish a srs. Hey major anderson
Two weeks ago. We intercepted imc comms. I feel like I should do something about that
A massive blast of energy was discharged at this location creating time distortion. I'm gonna stay in the same spot. I'm so short
I'm a short king
Roger that
I'll get some answers this wrist mounted device. We recover during operation grizzly should protect you
We know the imc have contracted cuban blisk and his mercenaries to protect something critical there
So watch it back
And anderson, you know how much I love writing death reports. So don't go along
The srs is a team
Oh
I have no idea what they were talking about
We are duty bound to uphold and fulfill special operation 217. We do recommend. We locate anderson's wrist mounted device before proceeding
Okay
I didn't see any device on anderson. It must be on the other half of his corpse. How do you know?
Oh, you probably look through my head to the security services building. I will provide access
Okay
I will remain here and scan the ring structure while you investigate the facility
You could just lift me up there
That was
I won't lie bt. That was pretty fucking cool
Uh
That was pretty gnarly dude. I don't remember this at all this part. I always never remember the latter half of games
Oh
Is
Why
Oh, one of them's so alive. Oh spooky. Oh, there's a couple so alive. Oh
All right
Am I supposed to run past them? I feel like I am
No
No, there I am
You're right
I
Just look at fucking bt. Just chilling out with this little fucking chickens
No, sorry, I have to kill you in a mirage
This is very weird
I don't remember this at all. Oh the giant orbiverse spiders out my window again
Is it sexy robots?
The dev team's community manager. Oh really cool
I agree. I agree that she likes something's missing from game
Thank you for showing me his buddhisi
There we go
Thanks
Mr. Anderson
Damn his ass jiggled
How the fuck did this happen to him?
Why do I look like a fucking
pressed mouse wheel to time travel
All right
I'm I'm a little lost too
Now like I can just like snap out. Wait, will they still be over there? Oh, they are
Additional laser meshes are online
Oh
Good
Oh my god
I got a robot's just fucking chilling
Sorry, oh it kind of shows where they were
Nope, no, thanks. No, thank you
Yeah, I'm good with that
Wow
Am I supposed to be in here? Oh, I don't think so. All right, let's just let's just hide in here for a moment
I
What the fuck is happening up there
I'm terrified. I'm not playing fucking
Alien what's what is this?
Everybody's supposed to go
Oh
I would honestly right to fight these things people. Oh, no, I wouldn't
What oh
I
So I'm just casually time traveling
Oh, there's a fucking helmet there
Yeah, why not
Six no
We're going forward with this the test must be completed
Pilot a fragment of Anderson's damaged log may be relevant here activating log playback
Whoa found something. All right. Oh shit
Old space and time issues. I didn't build it, but they're restoring it. It was the engineers from alien
What
Oh somebody right here
Oh
It's actually kind of just easier to fight these guys and crazy robot dudes actually
Yep, precisely. No, thanks
I'm good with that. No, this is where I came from, wasn't it? What the fuck?
I'm so stupid this way
If we don't cast the arch power now, we may never
Are you guys doing down there?
That's actually kind of cool
Ow
Remember in the space jockey went on a killing rampage on humans because it killed Jesus who was one of them
Is that the thing?
Okay, I'm gonna get behind them
I
You know confirming the kill as one does uh pretty nice. We love it
Anderson's log 342 the full weapons power source is called the arc destiny wishes they could get on this level
Doesn't look like they perfected the casing
This one's empty the arc must be somewhere else Anderson out
I haven't watched Peretius in such a long time. No, I'm good. I'm good with that
Oh
Just keep running just keep running just keep running running running
What do you do just run
Ow
Oh
Must be so weird to see a dude just like
Disappearing and appearing randomly
Now
Oh god, there's so many. Oh, I didn't mean to miss that
I jumped into that
You can play that game. Give me a break. Give me a break. Let me get my health back up
Handlock. Oh, yeah, handlock. Oh, oh
Um, where am I supposed to go?
Oh
I see
I can't really go
What am I doing?
Oh, hey
Wait, oh, what the fuck
All right, looks like it wants me to do this
I'll successfully deliver to both. Yeah, yo
Pilot the rings at my location contain a large amount of residual energy. This was the arc's final destination
Anderson's plan. Yo
Within close proximity to the center of the active rings. Sorry. I'm just like enjoying this story because I don't remember this
I'm pressing the wrong button. You sure I'll be safe over there. No, but a true militia pilot takes risks
It's that's me taking ideas from apex
Damn, that's hard
No, he's right though, he's right
Hey, timefall did steal so much from apex bro. Oh
They're really thinking that I'm good at this
Dr. Jefferson boil double tape looks like they went forward with the arc test
Despite my warnings to postpone, but what martyr wants martyr gets. I don't know how I survived, but I did
For now
Oh
I'm so sorry. I like archaeology. Oh, it'd be funny if you just fucking showed up like what the fuck
Uh, where the fuck am I supposed to go? Oh, I see
Okay
Oh
Uh
No timefall timefall totally ripped off apex bro
Like look at all the same the guns are the same like could they get less original like they couldn't come up their own guns
Like are you serious bro?
Oh
Now
They were targeting this planet's moving test this damn thing was just a test
Game is this timefall
They're going to hit hard and fall to you and they moved up the timeline. I have to get this intel to sarah
Oh, I still don't know what's happening
Oh
Exactly jokie exact what the fuck I gotta save him in the past
I can't
Get him
That was major anderson's final recording. Oh
Cooper based on your recon of this facility. I may have a plan. Meet me outside
Oh, meet me outside. How about that?
Am I supposed to fucking jump through that? Oh
Oh interesting
I would like to spend some time today to talk about the value of human life
Why is there always a dead body next to one?
No value to human life because I don't think you just died here
Oh
Ha ha get fucking jorked
Okay
Okay, she be I can smell the sarcasm from here
What no i'm not being sarcastic
Who has the opportunity to run by a best hole have a guy at pause and ask wait
Is there self-shelf vision this it'll be fine and time travel
I don't know why that's so funny to me. It's like they couldn't yeah, they could have definitely did like some stupid fucking gag
I recommend you meet me at the rings in order to
What the fuck
Hey big boy, oh
Sorry, sorry that was loud
It's hard to get it past those shields. Oh, no, no time travel fuck
Flank enemies to oh, yeah, I fucking know that
Pilot pilot
Oh
Is there a fucking puppy in there? Oh, thank you. I appreciate it Rob
Anything you meet me at the rings
Oh 360 no
Yeah, I'm not allowed to come over here
Oh
I'm sitting on fucking fire
Like there's puppies behind the door
Oh
They leave
No, fuck I can't cloak I can only
Oh
It takes a whole fucking clip
Hold on I'm just scratching like why are you where are you going? All right
I'm a true gamer now
Sorry, I'm taking the elevator. Let's take me a bit
You
Don't fucking run away from me
Motherfucker anyways
Pilot I've located the controls to extend the bridge to the rings. Yeah
Marked it on your head
BT you didn't fucking tell me there are puppies around
It appears that whatever actions you took in the past have caused the remaining automated security systems to be quite hostile towards us. Yeah
Do you want me to embark I don't uh, let's embark
Actually BT it would have been probably easier if you were doing your own thing
Another I think of it
I can time travel with BT
All right
Oh
I have marked the bridge controls on your HUD you will need to extend the bridge before the fold web and test pad explodes
Sorry I'm gonna just get behind them
Before the one explodes
I'll be fucking terrified that there's a Titan teleporting around me. I'm not gonna lie to you
I hate that I'm killing people in the past. They weren't you honestly didn't really do anything
I don't know why I need that
Extend the bridge oh what that
I don't think I can get up there
Am I supposed to do oh
Excuse me BT. I just need to
You you keep sitting pretty there
Oh, I forgot about the cool hacky knives
Any circumstances
I like how I'm randomly doing this now it's kind of weird how like we just switch what we're doing
BT where the fuck did you go? Oh?
Should we redo something
I feel like we should be leaving what am I doing scan the arc
Something tells me the bridge is there back in time
And she goes Nia. Yeah, I bet she does
All right, BT. Let's look in
Oh
And I Cooper breathing BT
I
Accidentally froze time this is awkward
Oh no now I'm gonna have to hop skip and jump through shit. Oh ride. Oh, that's fine. Actually. I prefer that. I hope there's a bunch of these
No, what's happening here? I'm tweaking
Okay, I'm pressing e am I too close. I'm sorry I had to flip around
Oh
Flashback
She comes your neck
It's gravity still operate that's a good point. That's a great question. Oh physics
Thanks
Well done pilot scan complete as thank you me the imc intend to destroy the militia planet of harmony using the full-scale version of this weapon
Damn, they're really like star wars up in here. Why is it raining? We must get this data to the fleet
All right
Oh, all right
I'm gone now
And you turn on a light it is dark in here
Okay, now I can see
Time stopped air would be like a wall of concrete
Really, that's a good point. It's a lot of like suspensions of disbelief we do when it comes to that sort of thing
Oh
Did I get up here Anderson is dead, but we can complete his mission if we can reestablish contact with the fleet
Why can't you jump when I'm inside you?
That sounds weird
Let's hope someone on our side is listening out there. There is only one way you're going so fucking fast
I'm just a little dude
You mean I can't be riding inside of you at this point. Are you are you shitting me?
What the fuck where are you going bt
Caution I'm picking up multiple contacts. All right. She's like stomping so angrily
Hostiles confirmed the stalkers appear to be programmed. Sorry. I'll I'll sand in your eyesight. So it looks more natural. Oh shit. That looks pretty sick
All right, let's do this dude. What's that?
bt come pick this up
bt
What is this fog?
The ground fog is a toxic byproduct of the beacon power grid
I recommend you embark when operating in hazardous and violence
Pilot I'm detecting militia forces inside that beacon control room. They are signaling distress patching in
Hey you out there pilot are you reading us?
We can use some help over here. This is captain Cole for the third militia credit here. I supposed to be walking
How's he not dying these stalkers and then make direct contact with the militia riflemen
That was fucking weird
This kind of isn't really working out
Tactical option run them over my 40 ton chassis can eliminate smaller enemies. Yeah, not robots that well though. I'm not gonna lie to you
Actually seems like it. Oh fuck it
What are you doing? Why does it take forever to kill you guys? Okay
Thread neutralized well done. This victory has raised our calm efficiency rating. No way, you know, it'd be funny
You saved our asses those stalkers just kept on coming we may not have lasted much longer. Yeah, I think you could have been fine
No, okay
I'm coming
Hey
I totally didn't let other teammates die before
What's up Cole? What is the status of the beacon?
The power is shut down
We've lost all control of beacon
Peacemaker or path find peacemaker pathfinder looks like a mini version of bt to be honest
I know he's like a like kind of like one of the robots in here that you like
This like kind of reworked, but you repair it. You good
Are they fucking
Who the fuck are you talking shit about this place just ain't built for humans
I feel like you guys are talking shit. You just gestured to me. Who are you?
Was a huge victory
Good luck, sir. I hope you make it back. We've lost too many down there. Well, the
All right later. I heard someone's been killing off blitzx team
Bye. Yeah, it's me. I'm him
Don't bite me. I'm just shooting guys. I'm just I'm just here. We just we should be ruined to and in shooting
space
All right, you ready? Are you ready sergeant russell?
You look a lot like sergeant kamata. Uh
I'm all these are stairs what stairs and this turtle up to protect their heads
Uh
Thank you for the plot help sir. Can I can I
Oh, sorry, I thought I could go through time again. So last buddy booty booty booty rocking everywhere
All right
I'll figure away
To monitor your progress the channel is open if you need assistance. Thank you
What's up with these walls
Scanning exposed power circuits. You should avoid physical contact. Thank you very cool for the time gifted
Got it. Now you're playing with power. I feel like I really didn't even need to ask
Yeah
Uh
No kidding. I'm not gonna kill him. See look it's pathfinder
Where the hell am I going?
Oh, you want me to go this way
Go on after you show me the way
Oh
Yippie softball
What
Oh, but I like the double take
I like the double take because I can probably
night people. Yeah
Yeah
Oh, see this will be helpful. Ah Marvin do something
I have 24 shots
And I did not need it
I
Explode oh i'm in a corner. I'm scared. I like how they're just doing their own fucking thing
You guys got
Wait, hold on let me 360
I didn't even click hold on
See you guys see that
You guys see that that was pretty sick
That was pretty sick
I'm gonna say
Oh, I'm gonna say that was pretty sick. That's all I'm gonna say
Uh, I think I should probably collab with vsbo vispo. I call them vispo vispo in vispo yin
Oh, don't touch the floor it's lava
Hello
How many times am I gonna say what is this place I do I not know fucking anything
Hello, oh it's amazed out here how deep does this thing go? Oh my god, where's torrent?
Can I jump
Oh
Dubs up an air horn and like MLG and a bunch of like memes popped up. How should I go up there? Yeah
Yeah, oh I can only double jump
I made it. What's up pathfinder?
Okay
Just in case gotta do a little double jump just like uh, I was torn
Detected
Oh
All right, how do I oh
Come here Marvin
Come here
Give that to me
Thank you. He's like what the fuck
Oh, I'm so sorry sweet. Do you want something else? I'll give you my flat line
Do you want my double take? I really like my double take. I'm so sorry, honey
Oh
What am I supposed to do here?
When I can just literally walk oh, I can get actually back up
Oh
How do I use the fuck oh see
Got fucking smushed
Oh, oh, sorry
Oh, hey, what are you guys doing? You're so cute. I'm so sad. I took it from him
Let's go yippie
I just fucking killed them
Oh no out
Oh my god
This isn't not why would the devs do this like the marvins are like little like pets
Why can't I jump I don't understand why I can't make that
It's very warm in here
Oh
Yippie
I
Like how it recognizes and waits till I'm there, uh, I'm assuming I do this one
Yippie
It's a bit windy in it. Is it too shy it's too shy in it it is
Well, oh check point
Oh, fuck
Oh
Please don't go out that would suck if this was timed. I'm happy. It's not I'm happy. They're a little bit more
They just wait for you to leave
Oh, I didn't see you there
No, oh you're so loud fucking die, bitch
Uh, I was out of ammo. Are you serious?
Are you what the fuck was that?
All right, let me just
All right, I like that I didn't scope in because my mouse my right click is broken and my front click is broken
Oh
Did I break it it's gone
Uh, you know what you show me the way
All right, let's go do this
Oh my
Yep
Yeah, that's me. Is there another one I would like to know what else to do here. Oh, actually fuck it. Let's try it. Uh, oh
Nope
Oh, that's right. Are you fucking serious? Oh
Oh
I'm not making it
No, watch out. No. Oh, okay. They stay off cool
Hello
Was it impressive me dying several times? I'm happy you thought that was nice
Uh, do you guys have better guns? I would like to reload my flat line
I don't want that gun nothing. I don't like it
What are you doing he's got the arc tool
That's impressive. I just took it off of a guy. I don't I don't think it's that impressive
Why are you guys gassing me up when I literally just started this job? What's that massive some amazing moves, sir auto loading shotgun
Fuck me
Actually
How about I like the double take
Oh fuck
Anyways, what if what are you doing there bud? Is that how you walk downstairs? Is that what you
No continue continue deez shake shake the shake that s
Uh
How do you know what I just did? Oh
Because I'm the one what am I fucking neo
That's yours
Again, if you got uh, if you got gifted
Make sure you take re kuma
I love that pieces
This is great. I'm having a great time now if only there were real people I would feel a little bit more validated
Good work pilot cover now we can jump start the power to get the beacon functional
That was a mildly suggestive bt damn. Oh my
Is there
Rule 34 of you the arc tool should be able to jump start
the manually
Let's hope that our tool was worth all the trouble that pilot better be careful
Open the fucking door shut up bro. You're not doing it high radiation levels detected ahead
Your suit will only protect you for a limited time inside the chamber. I suggest you move quickly
I wouldn't stay in there too long unless you want to be burnt to a crisp
You just mess this the case
You mean the whole world
Oh, this is what I'm supposed to be doing
Am I dead
What am I missing
How I recommend you exit the chamber immediately
No
Great now I have cancer
All right, we got power
Come on you wouldn't come on you wouldn't
Diagnostic complete power 100 percent
Initiate discharging reset uplink targeting module reset initiated
Oh, sorry. Sorry. I forgot I wasn't alone
80 percent 90 percent come on. I got to be a youtuber sometimes. I was too wholesome yesterday in my stream
Yes, I've seen kung pao into the fist. I've seen clips of it from the stream. I got the imc or on their way
The ymca
Do you have a fucking sword? What is that? I feel like there's a lot of pointless stuff on your back
Pilot this situation could use your skills. I just got here. It's my first day
You'll need to repair the beacon on site. You're back here as fast as possible
Do you not feel strange right girls? No, all right, let's go bc
pilot control
I forgot what it looked like
We're in like just more like a normie outfit with them
With them thing on the helmet. Where am I going?
All right, be careful. We've already lost a lot of good soldiers over there. Well, they're not me sergeant. So
Sucks to suck
I am the main character of this video game. I'm the protagonist
My memory recalls this pilot as an exceptional fighter proven well during the fracture operation clearly not good enough
Sorry
Fracture with the coloring of a major combat refueling operation conducted by the militia on the plane in victor
We sustained many casualties, but the fleet survived
Oh my god, you fucking scared me bt
You're right bt is the main character. Can you hello?
My scans detect a functioning uplink targeting module
428 meters northeast my analysis indicates a throw is our only option here. I can
You're fucking kidding
I'm incapable of insanity pilot
Uh, hold on. Let me uh put a smaller gun out. It makes me feel better
Uh, I can't believe. Oh, I wasn't ready. Uh
Ah
Oh my god, 95 meters projectile mass no 89 kilograms. I'm listening that
Sorry how to do the rtd2 screen
Good throw
Welcome pilot. Good luck over there. Come on. He's daddy. Who the fuck are you? Why are you still here?
The damn pilot
This goat
Get to the beacon now
Find the client among the last beat me
The fuck am I doing
Think that that's what it wants me to do
Yep. Oh, yeah, because it has a little fucking red things here
Oh
I don't like that. I have to I wish I could just scroll through them and instead of clicking see
Ah
Oh, what the fuck I forgot what gun I had it's a good one
Oh my god, fuck off
Oh
Oh, I miss you. Oh, you're a teammate. No, you're not
I'm
I'm gonna die
Oh
Actually, I'll take the hemlock
Just wanted a hug. That's way too bad
Get to the bacon. No
Who can I oh wait
Are you my friends now? Oh, fuck. Yeah, let's go
Yeah, I don't think you can make it over here. It's fine
Hmm, don't quite know what the point of that was
Hey, I forgot what gun I had
And I forgot to reload
Fuck
This is not it. Oh, perhaps it is
Oh my god, I can't even not even tracking you properly
Why
Sometimes I forget the later NPCs have a little bit more health. They don't have better AI
They just have a little bit more health
Hi, y'all
No, get the fuck out of here, bro. Get the fuck out of here. Oh, hey, Marvin
Okay, I didn't mean to do that. It's fine
Am I presuming I move this somewhere? Yes, okay
At least they can't jump like me. Oh, fuck. Don't fucking shoot me when I'm doing stuff
Can I reload? No, I can't. No, I was actually gonna have a full full clip
Look, they're all happy
At least these ones are happy
I
Where am I moving this to
This
I'm um, assuming so. Oh look a helmet
Oh
It's gonna be like one of fucking nine. I fucking knew it. Uh, I think that's a bit too far
So
Excuse me pardon and then we're gonna
No, you make that
Duma's so goofy. Yeah
Wait for your phone to charge
Yeah, I don't really know what I'm supposed to be doing here. I'll be honest with you because I don't know how I'm supposed to get over there
Am I supposed to move that one over there?
No, but then I'd have to go all the way back doesn't make that much sense
I
I'm a little confuzzled ladies and gentlemen. I'm not I'm not a puzzle person, you know not a puzzle person
All right, so let's move back here. Well, where am I going?
So that's fine
Can I make that? Oh
I see
Okay, I got it now buzzing go
Actually, I think I might have to die I think dying I think dying is necessary
I
Eh, maybe I'm doing this wrong
I just want I just want to see something I just want to see something I just want to see something
Fuck I didn't okay, and then move
What why are you guys looking at me like that? Is this not what I was supposed to do
What do you what do you mean madam, please?
What do you mean madam, please
Was that not
Was that not what I was supposed to do
Do
But not with the dying well, I don't know how else I would be able to do that to be honest
Because I couldn't
How am I
What the fuck how am I supposed to wall run up there?
Can it is there a crane the crane is down there can I climb
I
Can't make that jump what am I supposed to
Promise to be a platform around here somewhere. No
Can you take me up there
I could have jumped off the height in flat. Oh
Oh
Yeah, I'm fucking jumping like a motherfucker. Do I need to do anything here? I can't make that
I mean kilo one four
Yep
Because I fucking that seems like this is that clipped through it, but you know, it's whatever
Hey, it worked it worked guys. What can I say?
I think a little bit differently, you know
Open the fucking door
You think I can't run over there. You've already seen my running skills. Oh, you guys can jump
Thank you for letting me reload. I really much appreciate that
Oh, do you guys have any guns? I don't want exactly to use the like l star
Wow he moves. Yeah, why are you?
Oh
What's that? Oh
What
I can have a tick. Is there any guns over here? No
Oh
Go get him
No, you didn't really do much for me bud, but you tried that's what counts. I remember you did
Oh, I did
It's fine
Oh, thank you very much
I can't really see from the recoil
Oh
I
That's unnecessary
Oh
Where the fuck are you fucking kicked me you bitch
All right, we have a German now nine
I have other plans for the pilot other back in my suppose. Uh, I see
I see
You work for me now, bitch
Oh, I'm just fucking fell off. I don't know why it's giving me the opportunity to summon all these guys. I know
I'll take it though
Good you were at the controls move the dish to the far right to bring it within your reach
I
Sitrap
What are you fucking talking? Oh, this is why you gave me a bunch of dudes
Get on
Thank you for the checkpoint very kind
Oh, we may be missing a jump motherfucker
Hey, what's up
What's popping brand new it just hopped in
Pilot the module is in the projector of that dish
Is it
Thank you entire chat for telling me that that means situation report. I appreciate you
Please please
Please don't make me fall off
A yawink, thank you very much. Why do I wear the most casual outfit?
Protocol to mission update
Standing by for your return
Antony maintenance move
Yeah, I can't make it. No. Oh what oh, no
Guys, I don't think I'm supposed to be here
Don't fall off. Well, it's too light for that little minute
It's a bit too late
Okay, oh, oh you want to teach me something no, I'll figure it out myself
I'll figure it out myself
I
Okay, let me just go back up. Can I get back up here?
Oh, see there's a way down here
Uh
Yeah, there's always a way
Man she me fell off for real for real for real
drip combat readiness. All right, maybe I should just let the ghost tell me where the fuck they go
So I'll just waste my clips on this thing
Ghosty boy
Come on
Oh
No, I'm just an idiot
Why couldn't I make the jump before I don't understand me? I don't I have my slow moments
He sounds like Arnold Schwarzenegger
Oh
It's fine. We recovered
I am on my way
I am
On my way
Oh, it lets me reach that far suddenly. All right
Oh
You're like we really want you to understand that wall running is a thing
No, be too what the okay
Be
GVP not
I'm engaging hostile infantry
What where am I?
Oh, uh, oh
Didn't mean to do that
Oh, I gotta go up top
I
Ride him cowboy ride him Jesus fuck BT
Okay, get me in buddy get me it out fuck
Oh
Stop there's like
Oh my god, there's so many of you. Oh my god, can I
Oh
I can teleport I forgot
What do you guys are like upward BT can't get you so that's not really cool. It's not very nice
GbH
Oh
Where the fuck is this shooting come from
Did they fucking kill themselves I am a little confused they were shooting
All right
Hell yeah, I'm on a hot streak
I'm on a hot streak I can block with the sword you're lying
Just cool. I know you're not lying. I'm just like you're joking. I know you're not joking
Thank you for the tip
Very funny BT. Yeah, very funny. You're funny now. Give me that pain. Sorry a little bit of lowest
All lowest girlfriend moment
Hmm
No
Oh my god
Great
I like how I just get magnetized to his fucking hand. Oh my god. I'm gonna
Yeah
Okay, yepy
At least they're stairs. Oh look a helmet
I like how it's just like there. Oh, there's another one over there. Uh-huh
Hi boomie
I
LR
Sorry
Slow
God
No
I don't know what you're talking about
Uh, yeah
You want to be a hero, yeah
Okay, keep coming at me. I can't tell if you're australian or not to be a hero
Uh
Where?
Oh, how is anybody supposed to see that?
Yeah
Yep
Bitch, are you come back here? Yeah. Yeah, I finally got to punch one of you
No, perfect little plank how delightful
Sorry, I am busy
Yeah
That means i'm gonna fucking go toxy turvy. He's south african. That's what it is
Nice south african. I can't do a south african in this accent
Oh
Oh, sorry, it's a cut scene. I can't oh my god
That was fucking sick
You know what I just realized is it the same voice actors fucking optimus prime?
Cooper the dish is back online. Get back here. Mr. Helmut. I I don't care. It's it's it's not a it's not a priority
Yeah, okay, I was gonna say this is like wait, it's that optimus got you
This is Richter intercept and destroy that pilot then execute the remaining militia troops reapers inbound
Militia forces lock down the control room threats detected
Can I say it's a oh, that's pretty cool and it kind of like sun zone. That's pretty neat
Why are you fucking shitting yourself?
I
Like how I hold it up
Okay
I
I'm fine. I mean you're fine BT. You're good. Don't worry about it, buddy. I got you
Sick caution anomaly detected possible hostile type let's go
Nice, um, well, I thought I locked these two
Tempting I don't really like the
Roan the only thing as good as the melee. Let's try the ion
I
Leave you alive. Are you serious? Is this is this okay? I was gonna say I'm like, is this the boss it's on
Yeah, you seem like a nice dude
I
Just killed your friend
I don't need the laser core for this. I'll save it for the boss
Don't run away bitch
Take a look at man
Come on, all right
I love this fucking cut screen. Let's see what you got. Oh, you're the ear, dude
Because he sounds like he looks like he's a viking and he sounds like a character from vikings
Oh, that's crazy
Oh, you're so lucky
Wait, no, that's not what I meant to click. There you go. Why don't you walk on that?
Can you like
What the fuck am I I'm pressing the wrong shit
Okay, hold on hold on. Let me just gain my bearings right all the way over there
I might die because I'm playing stupid
Oh, jeez what is that?
I guess I'll also hide behind a rock
I
Are you all the way over there?
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine
It's fine. Come here, bitch come over here so I can finish you off
Sorry, what didn't catch that mother fucker. Anyways
They are very Tarantino-esque right get over here. Uh, he's dead
Oh
Actually, you know, I should probably watch this from bt. Oh, let me come on
We can stand and watch together with this with the with the lens flare
Nope step in front of me. I'm trying to watch broadcasting data stream awaiting response. Thank you Optimus
Someone's still up there
Oh, it's fucking the girl from firefly no, uh, what's her face from last of us
So say I don't speak dead
Thank you
Yippee
Hickled his tummy the voice. I think you know
Oh, that's correct
Yep, he became rock amosa
I'm a rifleman
Yeah, and I've done so much fucking shit, bitch. I swear to god, I thought you were
Transferred to a fully qualified pilot. I thought you were a brown lady. Cooper is my part on the comms
You look like a brown lady. I'm bad effectiveness rating now exceed. You're just lady with bad makeup
request permission to retain this link
Yet strong
Who put that mascara on your fucking face
Who thanks to your scan data who put this eyeliner on you who did you so dirty?
You're on typhoon. We don't have much time. Let's go. What about typhoon typhoid disease?
This one is kissed in action. Mwah
Yeah, she's gonna. Are you a bt? Mended
She's like the only woman around she's like, what do you guys think they're like, it's really good like they're trying to be wholesome
Take a bite of cookie
It's war paint
Mmm debatable
Boomi, what are you up to?
Oh, stretch my legs. Hi, Rena. What's up, Rena?
Rena, you can't I can't hold you right now. I'm putting my legs up because I was
I'll give you a hug. Do you want a hug?
Shake that chump. Da da da shake. I like to jiggle her. I like to jiggle her fatness
Rena's my cat
There's a lot of new faces today
Hello new faces. My name is Sheevee Cottonbum
Your face is so cute. You're so cute.
Your favorite girl failure Dom. I don't normally stream FPS's
But I wanted to have like an FPS week
um, I really I grew up playing a lot of FPS
but uh
Yeah
I don't know what else to say
Actually, Rena's not fat. Rena's a lot of sweet. Rena used to be 20 pounds and now she's like
Uh, normal size. She used to be a big cat
Now that she's older, I think she just doesn't retain as fat as much
Sorry, that was boomy. He just threw himself into my closet and fear and ran behind the dryer
by the way
How's Titanfall 2? Oh, love it. I played this game a year ago. It's nice to revisit it
you know
I'm not throwing insults. I'm sit. Did you not hear that crash in the background? I have a cat in my arms
my other cat Fia
Is paralyzed. She's not making that noise. She can't move
Rena's being held by me
That was boomy
Hello, Sheevee. I missed a bunch of streams because my power is out. How's it been?
Oh, that's okay. I hope your power here. I hope your power is back and you're not just like
messaging from a dying phone
Hey, I'm new. No, you're not. Get out of here
No, please stay. Um, boomy is just excited. He only has five more minutes until he's finally fed. What time is it?
8.55. You're right. I have my uh, I have something blocking my clock
I guess your cat wants your attention. Yeah, he always wants attention
If I promise it was most likely boomy
Yeah, one of you guys made that was really good. I think no, yeah, I think no one special made a made a meme pretty good. Pretty good
false
Um, in fact, I should probably put rain on the ground because she's probably gonna leap out of my arms when her food goes off
The power meter got ripped off the side of your house
What?
Jesus Christ, you're in your car
Oh man, that sucks
Who the did was it like a storm or something?
New viewers understand boomy never does it. No
stop
Diabolical thoughts lurking in boomy's mind. You never know
All renappers
I'll take a little break and feed fia then come back. How much was left I forget
Oh
I was gonna play Elden Ring after this, but honestly, I think I'll be too tired. You know, I think I'll be too much in sick
I just like want to play Elden Ring
I had to go do stupid stinky errands today
Uh, can you can you not step on my boob rena like I would appreciate if you didn't do that
Uh, can you out?
Man
Hi, now you're just sitting on my hand
I don't know what's happening here
I like all my regulars are like, hi, I'm new here. Please attention. Give please please
Oh my god, cat hair just went everywhere
Reena's pinned my uh
My right hand with her entire body it is I my hand is totally enveloped
In her tummy and she's laying on it like she's a chicken
Uh nesting on an egg
I don't know why she is how how she is like this. Um
And it's funny because like mind you picture this
I'm sitting in my
My my chair. I have the little foot rest up. Yes, that's one of you because I always get ahead of that little joke
Uh
So like my knees are kind of pointed towards my chest and my hand
Is resting on my leg both of my hands like I'm kind of just like like I'm fucking like I'm fucking l like I'm l from death note right now
And she has managed to walk on my desk
And lay on my entire hand on my right side
That's it
That's literally it
Uh, so imagine l but she had but l has she but he has a uh giant
Siamese cat just on one hand
But it's not like on like, you know l has it on his knees. No mine are like kind of further down
She just left because she heard me talking shit
Gotta let them know code she be 10% off gamer subs facts. Uh
Yeah, they just announced today finally about the uh anime girl thigh limited edition tub
I am on the tub with some amazing people. So it's
Really crazy. So if you uh, check it out. I retweeted on my twitter, but I am I might actually probably tweet about it on my
um
Not tweet about it post it on my youtube because it was really cool
Uh, once in a lifetime opportunity that I'm on a gamer subs tub
Um, they just picked one of us randomly
And they just picked me because they're just like, oh we need someone to fill this gap
And stronti's like here are my ladies
Um
Honestly, I hope in the future that we just get a veeler tub because I honestly feel really fucking bad
The other girls aren't on it. It kind of makes me sad. Um
But uh
Yeah, so one day I hope that we can get like we sell enough units you can get our own
Cat food dispenser my beloved
We can get our own flavor and stuff or like at least like maybe like a shaker cup. That'd be pretty sick
um
They saw the thighs so like we need those. I don't know. Uh, I see I see us some thiccum thighs
I see I see he's got some banging thighs
um, but again with the nuances of a cute and funny vtuber on that
That's probably why a flavor would be a lerby uh lemonade
obviously
Um might be loafed
Or thighs or no, I don't know. I I think the other girls have very like uh, zura or mercy is very recognizable
But it's just crazy because I'm like I'm right next to fucking shy lily on the tub
like can you believe that
And then like silver veil and like like what?
I think pink lemonade would be funny for like peeler. So like pink lemonade. That'd be funny. Um
But yeah, it's
It's pretty neat. It's
Pretty crazy. I I I couldn't believe it when strani was like, hey surprise. And this was like months ago before we even announced the gamer sub's
partnership
She was like, hey surprise. And I'm like, what?
The fuck me? Why me? And they're like, I don't know. I just picked you the artist was like I'll draw her
And I'm like
It's funny that it's my white self because again, it was before like I changed stuff. Um
That's fine. I don't really care. It's just nice. It's just really cool to have that in general
One day it'll be me. It'll be tan. She be on the on the tub
Um, let me feed
I'm the star scream of veeler. What is that supposed to fucking mean goal?
I
Don't know. It's so amazing able to put me on the tub if someone's famous. Yeah as me as me. I'm so famous
They probably I'm think I was like thinking I'm like those girls probably see me like also tagged under the tweet
That fork posted and it was like who the fuck is she?
Who the fuck is that like who is this?
literal who with us
They're probably like who is like they probably like it'll be really cool if one of them like follows me because of it
Like imagine like a little cheeky, uh shyly follow
What maria is sending me something
what
What did maria send me?
What
Why did chat make boomy black marie, what are you talking about?
What do you mean? Why did chat make boomy black?
Marie, huh?
It's a shadow. I took a picture of him
Oh my god, marie is marie. I I I I cannot I cannot
I
Cannot
I'm gonna off that can piece. All right. I'm gonna feed fear
Boomy's from the hood
Maybe
I rescue boomy from the south from mississippi
Are you from mississippi because you're the only miss who's pissed at sipper
Thank you
Are you ready to be fed baby girl?
Okay, before I pick you up and stuff I am going to grab your food
What
Why don't you guys knock something it's a few years water in the swimming
Okay
Reena, why are you looking at me like that boomy let rena eat for the love of fucking christ you're eating all the food
Reena come here
Boomy I'm gonna have to start feeding you separately because what the fuck
Come here
Oh
Hello, it's me distant she be
Uh, if you're new here
I have three cats. They are all signees
Boomy and fia are just over a year old boomy is a year in two months
Actually, no
Boomy's a year
I don't even know uh boomy is what a year in a month older. No boomy is a month older than fia. I can't think
Um
And rena's 14
Reena's my elderly baby
And um
F sadly has an auto-immune disease that makes her unable to move
And this happens periodically. It's like uh when a when a car runs out of gas she just runs out of gas
completely
And she's on the side of the road and she needs a little pick me up
She her disease it actually happens in humans too it's called misethene and gravus so she takes uh
Uh
I forget what how it actually works. It's like a type of thing that helps her body communicate that she wants to move
She's getting better every day
She's walk. She's been able to move before she's fine. Um, just sometimes she's
cat
So I have to feed her by hand
He's eating all the food because he's a fucking pig
I
These cats are very prone to obesity. So I really have to watch boobies wave. I don't I don't need booby being bad
I have an automatic feeder. I might have to like temporarily
Get rid of it booby's gonna
impulsively eat the food
Um rena I used to have a different feeder when it was just rena and she would have the food
dispenser
And stick her paw into it and somehow get more out and that's how she got so fat at first
Hi, rena. Nice. I'm talking about you, ma'am
Yeah
Are you awake?
Hi
Am I here for you as I move her?
Don't worry. I'm not putting you in the litter box. I'm just sitting down in the chair
She's like what's happening?
Oh
That's it. I got the blanket in the water
Was she high no squeak. Yeah gotta hold her like a baby
Hold her like a baby. Yeah, hold you like a baby. There you go
You want it
Come on
Yeah
Where you want to go?
Do you not want to eat in my lap? Do you want to eat someplace else?
Is this too distracting for you? You don't like to be the center of attention
You don't look at me with that goofy face. Come on
There she goes
Have some kitty crunches
Don't worry for you. It's just me moving from the microphone. She's got so scared
You don't have to wrap against it
Boomie go away
You do not need to eat and rena's trying to eat now that boomie is away from the food bowl
And there's barely any food in it. There's like probably like a couple pieces of kibble because boomie ate both sides
No boomie boomie don't eat that
Oh my god
Can you get off my desk go? Thank you
You
So now we're gonna see here listen to my cat crunch
Here's your cat mutt pain
One time I know I actually know I have done this on camera before
That's when I was bottle feeding her because I had to but she wasn't able to chew but some point
So I had a bottle feeder
Fia don't get distracted by the microphone. She's like sniff
Ma'am
Ma'am continue eating please
Fia Fia please here
I don't like pretend I'm dropping more food in for her to continue eating sometimes
But I just pick up what's in the bowl and sprinkle it in and she's just like oh she added more
Here
Hi
Hello my little gremlin
Hello nugget do you want water first is that why yeah, let's give you a little sippy sip
Let's give you a little sippy sip
Here's some water
She's slurping
Chug chug chug chug chug chug
Oh my god, she's crazy
I've never seen someone from the sorority do this
She's out drinking the frat bros
How is alpha alpha pi gonna respond?
Yeah, this is a hydration check everybody
Yeah
Some good slurps
You like some more kids
some more kibbies
Kibbies for to get oh, did you just move your legs? What was that?
You just moved your leggies
What is up with that?
Come on
Please don't tell me you need to eat from my hand. Sometimes she like insists on eating directly from my hand. Here you go
Get it
Come on for you. I believe in you
Please
Don't make me put you on the couch
I like sit her up like a human on the couch and I feed her
Boomi go away
You do not need to be on my desk right now
Go where's the water bottle go
Hear him squeak an alarm. Yeah, because you know it's better
I walked away to like go make myself an english muffin for breakfast the other day and he was
On top of fia eating her food and she was screaming
Kibbies like
I know it's not crazy for you. She's looking at me like what is the noise you just mean little girl. Come on
You want any from me?
She's so she's so focused on the microphone. I'll have to feed her somewhere else
Because I threatened to shoot him
No
Okay, you're gonna hear her squeak as I get up because I'm adjusting her
Come on, baby
Now she on the couch she's popped up like a little human
And then I put give her a little bib
And then she'll eat like she's I have to take a picture of her and she'll eat like she's a kid like watching tv
I was
She was like watching. I was I think I was watching um
Markiplier play
Five nights and 30s in for fit
and she was just like
Eating the food but she was watching the tv and it was just so funny to me
And because she like for some reason she just really likes Markiplier's voice
She's like with dark and deep voices
Like she has my dad's voice
Come on, baby
I know you call me
Are you gonna she like
Can be really particular like I have to like sit next to her on the couch
And I give her moral support
To eat
All you're so cute
All the baby
Okay, let me grab my phone so I can see chat. I'm gonna sit with her on the couch while I feed her
So I'm gonna be ventriloquist for a second because I can't see what you guys are saying
Oh
When you're sitting in the cat tree like I took the picture this morning
Staring at him
Go away it's V is time to eat
You want you to sit like that why you sit like a truck driver you made it to the couch. He is Garfield. So do we are correct
What do you mean get her boomy
Why are you looking at me? He's like sitting and jumping me in that pose
I don't know why I like I try to like I'm trying to teach him how to gap up like I try to like fist bump him
Like I'll slap like I'll I'll
Not like slap his paw, but I'll like you know how you like you gap someone. You just like you go slap the bump
I'm trying to teach him how to do it
When he's in that pose
It's kind of working
I'll take a picture of how it looks like
It's hard to take a photo
Yeah, I think it was a work in progress and
Thank you for letting me take a little moment to feed my cat everybody by the way
It's called close to picture right now
Live Theo reaction
Yeah, right now you you make you
You do that girl
Are you looking at me like that Theo?
He's giving you bombastic side eye right now. Is it because you've been on close to me?
You need to set up a little bit more movement
You
Bet she needs to drop it here
Sorry for moving you I know you're doing that I feel
Good
Now you look comfortable
If he is eyeing you feel warm
Here you go
Hello
Good job
You
You take cat it's a marlin everything for this
What happened to Theo? She has a uh an auto immune disease or she can't move
So she paralyzed from
a bow like
The chest down I'd say she's getting better. Um, so what is it's like
Her body
Can't communicate with her muscles to move like there's a chemical reaction, you know that has to occur
For that to happen and she's been saying I believe the amino acid to do so
Um, her body stops producing it
And it means assistance to producing otherwise you kind of like just stop moving
And this is the second time this has happened
The last time um, we thought it was like a one-time thing
So we like I didn't know that it was chronic
Right now can you stop scratching so well? I don't know what you're doing in there, but you're not stupid
But
Yeah
I'm just sitting on the couch with her because she just did she insisted on being on the couch
Now she's
Now we're hanging out
So
I might go quiet for a moment
Oh
I hope you had a good time touching grass views from playing in Titanfall and I think I'm almost on the game. I'm not quite sure
I
Oh
They when we like posted up ready to take
He has left over
And I have to hide it in the microwave
So he because that's the only place you can't get into because you can open doors and cabinets
but the microwave
You need phones, baby
So you can't do that
Nice try
Okay, you're gonna hear uh Fias actually no, you know, I should just be for this you guys don't need to hear my cat using the bathroom
I'll be back in a second
You
Hello
Oh
Oh, it's at my desk already
I'm silly
I
Where's my blanket? Oh, it's behind me
Did you swap out the fuck I didn't do it? Oh my god, I got distracted by eating tomatoes from my mom's garden
You
Let me come out of the closet, please
I'm sorry
I'm not
Excuse me, you guys go. Boomi, there's nothing in there for you
Back up
Boomi get out of the closet
Why are you standing up like a human there?
So go get the spring
Right, let's not your time to jump in there. Okay Jesus Christ
You
Yeah, my friend can do this little brother from the wild born berries really well
She goes crazy. She's the one that I get the R2D2 voice from that's Salem
Salem does some funny voices as well. I got some tomatoes here. Boomi go away
Hey, I have some tomatoes here and I have some ranch
Boomi was trying to steal the ranch when I was like seeing if it would taste good with the ranch
And he licked the cap so I had to wash it
It's pretty my mom's tomatoes are pretty good. They're like better. Um and store bought
They're so sweet but also a little tangy
Being a single mother sounds rough
Extremely oh, I never put my phone back up. I'm just staring awkwardly
Hmm
There we go, there we go. Here we are brothers
Are we all ready to lock in the children are tucked in bed?
Boomi is drinking water rena is laying on
a
Piece of cardboard that is now her favorite spot from a box
That my whiteboard came in. Thank you guys for the throne gifts by the way. I already started using the whiteboard
I was also just dipping green beans in it. It's very good. Just like homegrown green beans
Now I'm also giving me a spaghetti squash, but I don't know how to cook spaghetti squash. I'll have to figure that out
Ready for lock in ready for pop lock and drop it
Pop lock and drop it
I used to hate ranch
Then in like the last like two years I started liking it so weird
I used to also hate cheese
And now I just don't like eggs
I don't know why this is
And now I like I'm kind of indifferent to cheese now
My cheese is all right. I don't know why to you
I'm not like super into cheese
Um, but if somebody gives me an egg like I'd probably rather not eat it like I'll eat it
but like
It's like an egg sandwich. Sometimes if I don't finish the egg sandwich, I'll just pick off like the bread and the
What's it called?
like the meat
And I'll just eat that and I'll just not eat finish the egg
I do like grilled cheese depends on the cheese. Yeah mercy got you. No, I've been like that for a while
And she's allergic to eggs so isn't she oh wait, is she I don't know how she was allergic. I could be totally wrong
No, I don't like it
I hate blue cheese though blue cheese is disgusting
Blue cheese. No, thank you
That's a negative for me dog
It'd be funny if like the game ended right here
Hi
What's really weird is that like all other
All other
Titans
Feel very just like that. They're just robots. Oh shit
Oh my god, I totally forgot about actual Titanfall
Um, whereas BT has is very humanized like her like
They don't really care about their Titans. It seems like there's no like
Humane acts aspect of the other ones
Sorry, I'm chewing on tomatoes here
I was already um, is this to be like doing something
I
Was just a fancy cut scene
They're dead it's okay
I wonder what happens if you kill the Ronan before or I wonder if they have to die
Oh
What's happening here all right, let me just electric smoke now none of us could see excuse me
Can I have your battery I want the battery
I have your battery. Oh nice. Can I have that battery? You guys don't need it, right?
I forgot the Ronan service like randomly really powerful
Thank you for destroying that mind
Tomatoes or tomatoes tomato tomato potato potato
Vanguard of advance AI
Interesting
But it's like even like her she like she has a vanguard Titan like we're all vanguards here
Sorry, I'm just gonna save you chat. Do I need the batteries for
Um, try my best here
Oh
Like
This is fun being in a giant fucking robot
VH
Do it
This is crazy. Oh boy is lasering me. Holy crap
What the heck I was so confused for a second
I didn't even know he's behind us. Is everybody else fucking dead like where is everyone?
Where's my team?
Where's my team bro?
Oh, why you gotta
Yeah, I am
Right now what funnel
Punch him to death give me his battery. Did you take it bitch? It's my kill
I'll get to the tunnel what fucking tunnel
You know, I kind of miss
I can't I don't know
I'm wondering what maps they have for Titanfall 2 because I never played timefall 2 multiplayer to be honest because the servers were down
um
So I I wonder what the type of maps they have because I really like Titanfall 1 maps
What are my cats doing? What do you do? Oh, Boomi's playing with the toy. That's fine. I thought he was eating something
What is this? Oh, that's pretty neat. Can I get your gun?
We have like a little machine gun. Is there a battery around? No
Quick electric smoke
Sick
Can I stop?
I'm trying my best
Oh, it's a sports
Hey
Let's dance. There's gonna be no dancing. This is a long-sighted thing, bro. Where are you going?
Actually, it's two-sided because we're like gangbanging
Am I
You're about to get lucky and dead
Yeah
Kind of sick of you guys shooting us
I don't know what my cat's doing in the background
What are you all
Braina is literally having so much fun on a piece of cardboard right now. I love her for that. Am I supposed to go up over here?
We've got to get to that shit before it takes off take those Titans out pilot. I don't see any looks like you took a wrong turn
What
I need a battery
Get out of the fucking way. Oh my god, this fucking bitch
I
That's her staying in fucking front of me
Yeah, she's like literally and she like mind you like rena is older
She's 14. So just to see her jump around like a little kitten full of joy is quite adorable
It also looks like she's break dancing on a piece of cardboard. So there she is. We still have time to intercept the arc
Move move. Sorry. I'm busy sniper real gun charges up while zoomed
Mine that looks neighbor anime Titans down vertical take off have a great
Hostiles
Where are you? Where is she?
Oh, she's where's where the how did me on? Oh
Are you good? Are you a good guy?
I can't tell you are here blue
Oh
Geez can I can I can I walk in?
Okay, so if I
How do I hover
I
How do I do that little oh my god, did you hear that like oh i'm gonna die uh
Did you hear that bang against my window? Yeah, that was rena running into it. No walk on that's not nice
In that core
I can't remember what titan I used a lot when I was doing this stuff black or do it
Why am I so close go no no i'm gonna die if I get too close. Oh my god
I don't really think it was nice. So thanks
I do that thing where I can lock someone down
Oh, oh no, no not me. No
Shut up
She okay, she's fine
She's just sitting there now
They get excited and so what they do they jump on the cat tree and it's against my window
That's what they bang into the cat tree
And uh
I just make silly long noise
No, and she only started doing that because actually you know what I won't blame for me for that that's definitely rena
Because rena's did that before I even had for me. So
Before I gave birth to him
How are you not dead? Oh, are you a good guy?
I
That was weird
Tether trap
Perfect
This is actually pretty good for the distance
I actually
Shut up I just killed like the same dude
Sometimes I just want to run around and like kill these guys because they're just
I
Oh
Come close
What are you gonna do?
Don't you dare take it bitch
I really think that's how that works that's fine
Who are you shooting at
You're not nobody
Scratching my eye
Enemy's locking up. What am I doing?
I press E instead of w when after I was done scratching my eye
Don't run away come back
Oh
I'm on fire
I
Don't even know what I'm shooting at. Oh, he spun around
Surrounded and dead
I'm sorry
Oh
I'm supposed to step on you yippie you guys have all these batteries and you're like dying that sucks
Am I not hitting
Can I uh do a little
Oh
I'll use your own thing to walk
Salvo color way
Hold on
Why are you still alive? I feel like these things have more health
What do you guys do over there?
Can I do the both of you?
Help burn away
It's fine relax
Who the oh, they're shooting at not the right people
We tighten down
Yeah, kick them getting enough on them. Oh
Oh my god, he's kicking my ass hold on. Let me run away
I'm still alive
Why didn't you guys kill the dude behind you? I don't
It's mine
Ah, I can't fucking see
BT I get it. Don't worry. I got you
Uh
Oh
Stop spinning
What are you shooting at I just
I don't know what the target is there
I
Don't know
Everybody else is dead that sucks. Well, it's real life. We're the main characters
Uh
I'm back here. I'm back up
I can't really do that
I
Did that actually happen? Sorry my own thing. I don't
I don't quite get that
I feel like we should have more Titans on our team. I feel like this should be a thing
Except oh they there they are and we got reinforcements
Oh my god, where did you come from? I can't hit you. Oh you hit me
ouch
Sorry boys you're telling me I can't get that you tell me I can't fucking get these
Oh
Are you
Are you fucking shitting me? Okay, I get it. I picked up. No, you don't look so hot BT
I have to walk on it first thing you to pick it up like it means something
Ah
Why why would you take on me?
Oh god, why would you do more time falls on me?
Oh my god, what is happening? I'm not gonna die. I'm gonna literally fucking stop telling me
About that. I don't care
Yeah, what the fuck am I supposed to do there? I don't
Uh
What it makes you vulnerable I'm kind of I'm kind of irritated by the
At least I spawn in whenever he's almost dead
Why do you not finish what you started she just lets him live
This one didn't even drop a battery
Oh
Whoa
Scorches fuck me up, bro. Good morning. Our reactor is unsafe. Okay. Yeah, you know, let's just
Be playing it real say
Oh my god, where did the fuck did you come from?
Shield bitch drop it drop it
Oh
That's mine
What are you talking about this ship?
I'm getting to it. At least this is slow. The arc is headed your way. I'll let Viper take you from here. See you soon
Are you serious?
I'm not too late, but I just like lose the game
Okay
Why are you saluting
Did something happen?
Boomi did you oh my god boomi put god his toy under the couch. You're on your own, bro
He's trying to grab it with his little hands like a little otter
We're gonna just watching him amused. What is up, huh?
Boomi what are you doing?
You're not supposed to bring under the couch again
At least that'll occupy you
Hear that ring in your ears that's a side of war son. What ringing?
Or the why do I have a cannon?
Okay
Feel like we should be flying faster
Oh rena's standing on me
We've got the drop
Oh, I think I missed
Yep, that was the one I got
Just burn past it. We have to catch the draconis
I gotta follow on that
What the frick is that?
I've got no I thought I was just a dude
I'm dead
Uh
Ow
My wrist should be fucking broken
Uh
BT I feel safer if I was inside of you to be honest, can I can I get in there?
Can I please
Oh, are you gonna fucking throw me again here we go fucking throw me
Are you sure about this sure about this bt
Thanks optimus
He just throws me at the ground
Oh, what because I'm like I'm not making that
What's up draws
Without crashing time your jump
Did I fall off? Did I like walk too close off and you'll have to work your way forward
I'm gonna get as close as I can without crashing time your jump
Oh
That was not a graceful jump, but thank you. I appreciate it. Why do I have a spitfire? I don't want this
Fuck sorry, I have to kill all of you
I can't really tell what's happening
Oh
I don't like that I'm sideways
My other grenades, please
How can you see what I'm doing oh
Oh
Am I at a ammo?
Hold on let me find out what is this?
No, this isn't really doing much with against the shield
All right, this isn't really fucking killing anybody
Are you why do I feel like they're hitting me?
Oh
I actually don't like this site at all
I feel like it's throwing me off
Ah
I'm not controlling this
Oh, there's weapon rocks in the walls. I see I'm I'm literally blind when I play FPS games
Oh shit
Oh
Oh, I know fucking pistols
The last two
Surprise bitch
Why is this thing fucking dying?
Oh
Like I'm gonna run out of ammo soon
Oh my
Just take a moment. I'm getting carsick
I
Nice try
That's super cute
Ah
I'm losing my footing. I'm just gonna hit fire because
I
Oh, I could hack these guys
Ah
I
Did I get gone too? I don't I don't recall
Hey, I don't know how styles in sight cooper stand by the six four coming aboard. I'm ready
Anytime just doing my job ladies
We'll also need your help
Copy that fair on my way
The bridge is through that hangar over there any ideas
How'd you get here? Did you also come over here on that? I need me to do
Gates, but what is this halo reach? Uh, one of you guys better not die and I cry because I don't want to relive that again
I love this job. Well, it's never boring. What the fuck you're all stavis
Oh
We got the drop on them
I'm gonna make that
Is
Drag out
Dead
Ah
There's a cat by my feet surprise
Like that
Ah
Reena you're kind of handicapping here
Oh
Ow, how did that happen?
Kind of abuse because you threw it
Follow me
Come on, keep up. I am in front of all of you
Uh, oh, I may have warned them
Close your fire is bulletproof. We're gonna breach the glass take your marks
I got by the stairs
I'm ready to fucking throw nades pilot cooper. Are you ready? Yes, sir
We're ready
I thought he just stood there
No, why am I that's how it's done. I didn't really do anything. I kind of just do stuff
No, why do I have to do it?
Why do I why can't she do it? I don't
Cooper you still have control of the bridge use your data knife to steer yourself right behind the draconis data knife
Get bt back to cooper
Can I please crash us the
The temptation to come on
I know it won't let me
It literally won't let me crash us
Can I go faster the left
That's the correct heading just keep the stick there. Yes queen
Okay, Lily just wants me to match the fucking same thing the correct heading still left fine
I'm right, but nothing I'm gonna do is gonna change anything
Six four just shut up and let him do the driving. Thank you. Jesus. Fuck. Thank you bear. Oh my god
I'm gonna drive us to do a fucking cliff at this rate
I
Can't even see what's happening. Oh, hey, what's up?
If you want to drive then you be my fucking guess
Marina please don't lay on my
That's it go XLR. She's thinking about it
I
Break the glass. Oh, hey bt
Oh
I have glass in my eyes. Thanks
Cooper will cover you from the rear take the deck and get to the draconis
Sick
You got some skinny legs you skipped leg day
I do like their fucking introductions. Oh
Oh, I mean what it automatically picks something from here realize I don't
Quite understand that what does this do? I mean, no, what does this do? What does this do?
It's not doing it. I don't know what it's supposed to do
I wish I wasn't by myself here
Oh
Oh, that's what I have
I'll take that
Brass orbit 0.0923 move in
What a fucking pussy taking cover
Tell me you're rich
The kill I am almost full health
I don't really think you're hitting at all
I can still hit you if I'm covered
You're looking at this. Oh, actually, uh, let me leave. I need that
Yeah, you hear that
Oh, that's where that comes from. You hear that ringing in your ear, son
Ah
What the fuck
Where is he regrouping prime three check right press forward. Where are you?
Oh
And it's here moving in for the kill. No, you're not you're not you're not
I'm trying to brush
Piper's got you in the pipe five by five
No, thanks
I want yours. Oh, what the fuck does that do nothing?
Excessive damage warning or you need to move a little faster than that
Yeah
Rain are you just nesting on my desk
It's not fair that I got to fight three guys. I didn't mean to heal
Thing oh my god
Fuck rain up
I'm sorry cat is laying. Oh my god
All right
No bt don't fall off
This is your stop. Oh, how are you hitting me when I'm behind this and I can't pick this up
Oh my god, no, I can't where is it?
I don't know if that does it makes me feel better. Oh
I feel like I shouldn't have this build
Oh, why do you why do you do that when I I don't can I have the battery?
I
For one we're taking cover brass four visual point oh nine two three move in
Really take the cover you're kind of just hanging out
Ah
And it's in moving in for the kill
Oh
I thought it said I had the laser shot. Do I know it?
Speed is light. I'm so confused. It like got rid of my laser shot. What just happened. I don't understand
I'm quite confused here
Do you guys have any batteries
That required
Uh, I I oh I could charge that
I know I was trying to use my laser core and it wasn't letting me
And it's got core break hard too. Well now. Oh now it does when I can't even hit him
I guess I am i'm gonna die
Even north star would actually probably be best
Okay
No
Wait, so it puts me in the middle of the fucking fight. I don't I'd rather just start it over at this point
I
What the frick I can't even tell where he has me tethered
Uh, I don't have a thingy I keep forgetting I'm doing I
Do
Bro, I'm just not thinking straight right now
He hits me once
I get those fucking tethers away from me
Nice
Two can play this game, bitch
Yeah, I shouldn't have never done whatever the fuck that was
Oh my god, it's so hard to read you when you're floating in the fucking air
I'm gonna
So close to killing you
Oh, no, you got your fucking thing back. Oh battery battery. I'm gonna die. I'm gonna batter
I'm going for it bt
I can't find it. Oh
Oh my god, I'm fucking choking
Oh my god, bro
Right now you look like a chinchilla. Did you know that you know you look like a chinchilla
What's up? Hi. Hi new girl
I'm a big mama
You
Rub the baby cat for strength
Kiss the kitty cat for strength
It is a default seem good. No, I think what the north star it's good because then I can fly and kind of meet him
expedition
Actually, you know, let's try let's try I'll I'll go with what you said
I
Yeah
Oh
My god, I'm getting my ass 8
I'm not sure what's going on.
Here you go.
Regrouping.
Prime three, check right.
Press forward.
First core ready.
Man, it's got core.
Good tone.
Third tone.
Fox 10.
Yeah, you're fucking going to die, bitch.
Oh, you can see me, you can see me, you can see me, you can see me, you can see me.
Yeah.
Nice.
You just got to stick with the classics.
Oh.
I didn't mean to shoot that.
Oh, sorry.
Let me run all the way fucking back here.
Nina has hotdog between herself, hotdog herself between me and the desk.
Okay, so she literally is a little hotdog, her ring.
Okay.
Oh, you motherfucker.
I can't really do anything.
BT.
Oh my God.
I need to get the fuck up.
BT, BT, BT, let me get inside.
BT.
BT, BT, BT.
I lost a hatch.
Need cover, need cover.
No, no, no, no.
Aim for the cockpit.
I'm aiming.
Just fucked.
Now I want your fucking robot.
Fuck you.
You thought you could hurt BT?
You motherfucker?
No.
None of my watch.
You okay?
You okay, bro?
Your arm's gone.
Okay.
This shit is rapidly losing altitude.
He's at the shit.
You should just take his arm.
Do you need, can't you just like attach your arm back?
Oh.
The containment unit is too large to carry.
We must improvise.
Oh, what would you like to do?
Fucking hell, BT.
What are you doing?
BT, no.
I cannot reach the arm.
Cooper, I need your help.
I got you.
I'll grab it with my hands.
That doesn't seem like that's safe for me.
What do I do?
How, this doesn't really make any sense.
We need to get off the ship.
We are running out of time.
What am I, W?
What am I supposed to do?
I'm supposed to just keep holding W.
Sorry, I'm going Celestial.
This way, Cooper.
I'm dead.
BT, I'm clipping BT.
BT, help.
BT, I'm shaking.
BT.
What are you doing?
Protocol three.
BT, no.
Get the arc out of here.
Negative, we are trapped.
I will not lose another pilot.
BT.
Brace for impact.
I love you, BT.
I'm actually crying.
I'm not even joking.
BT.
I need a tissue.
I don't think I'm ready.
I forgot I was wearing mascara.
What the fuck?
I am fucking the both of you up.
What did you do to my boy?
Tell him Optimus.
I just grabbed his fucking hands.
I think it would be fine.
Where's my knife?
No.
What?
His feelings?
Get fucking got, bitch.
Nah, I'm just a smart ass motherfucker.
What the fuck are you wearing?
You're wearing a dumb ass outfit, bitch.
That's fine.
I'm ready to die.
No, BT, don't do it.
BT, don't do it.
Now open up.
I'm going to shoot your pilots in the head.
You still remember numbers, don't you?
I'm going to count to three.
No!
One, two, three.
Nah, that wasn't so hard, was it?
What the heck?
That's the problem with teams.
If you don't win together, you die together.
I'm going to shoot your pilots in the head.
I'll be grabbed you.
Yeah, yeah.
Get me up, get me up.
Kill all, BT.
No!
I'm crying.
I hate this.
I know this was happening, but I hate this.
He was...
He was just a boy.
BT, no, I'm dying here with him.
I don't want to do it, no.
BT!
BT.
It's okay.
I can't do it without you.
What?
Your head?
Don't worry, BT.
I'll take you with me.
A part of you will always live on.
What the...
Give me your eye.
Yeah, give that to me.
I'm going to fucking kill everybody.
I don't know where to go.
I can't fucking see.
I'm killing all of you.
Especially that fucking bitch, so...
I'm going to hold this gun right to your fucking head.
My game is lagging.
Oh, I totally forgot about this gun.
I'm fucking busy right now, killing bitches.
That's not where I'm supposed to go.
I can't really copy right now.
I don't know what a click is.
Are you fucking shitting me?
Shut up, game.
I'm so angry.
I know the gun doesn't for me.
It's just habit.
Oh, fuck.
Nope, I still fucked it up.
Don't worry about it.
I don't care about melees.
I'm shooting them all in the head.
For what they did to my boy.
It's hard to do this at the same time.
I'm not going to lie to you.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Anyway.
It's kind of like such a weird thing to have at the end of the game.
Just like a gun that shoots for you.
It is a very satisfying revenge, I will say.
It's still very odd.
Oh, my God, the anti-guns.
I was chilling in his fucking head.
No.
I don't have a Titan.
My Titan's fucking dead.
Who are you?
Fs.
Okay.
Hi, Fs.
Oh.
BT, new body?
New body?
Who is this, BT?
Jack.
Not Cooper?
Okay, that's fine.
Ooh.
Okay, same day to core.
Fuck yeah.
Can I?
All right.
I cried for no reason, but it's fine.
Fuck you.
Ooh, I have a Gatling gun.
I have a Gatling gun, I don't know things.
Fuck off.
Excuse me, I'm angry.
I'm killing all of you.
Your murderous rampage.
Get absolutely mowed.
I don't even know what this is.
What is this do?
What am I doing?
Smart core.
Oh.
Fascinating.
Fascinating indeed.
All right.
Anybody else?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Why do I feel like I can't do any, like, special things?
Oh, is that to be changing the type by now?
I don't know.
It's very satisfying.
Yeah, I'm trying my best out here.
Oh, yeah.
I am having a hard time doing anything right now, to be honest with you.
Sorry, it's a situation report.
Yeah, what does the G do?
I don't quite understand what I'm doing here when I press G.
Am I changing the bullet type?
It just disappeared.
Well, I'm sorry.
This tie-in is awkward.
What does this do?
It's like anti-altering, I don't know.
What's happening?
It's not really explaining what stuff does.
That's fine.
Oh, what is this?
Sorry, what?
The kill streak.
That's nice.
I'm having a good day.
You had to squish him, bros.
I did that with one hand, because I was scratching my eyebrow.
Stop.
You don't want to make me step on you.
There's my, uh, there it is.
I didn't mean to press it.
Stop punching me.
Oh, you're going to kill me.
I'm stuck.
I was in a corner.
Spread of fire rate.
Okay, that's what I thought.
I had a feeling.
Oh, I got to do this all again.
This isn't putting me in the fucking middle of it like before.
Great.
Yeah, Scorch, Scorch does, uh, Scorch does some shit to me, I realize.
At least I'm going to stop on all of y'all.
Let me back up.
Oh, okay.
I didn't really have to do anything.
I never get that they help me.
Okay, let me just step on some dudes because they're kind of being annoying.
I'm literally being fucking shot on.
Try to stop this laser.
Oh, okay, nice.
Okay, I'm backing up for this fucking Scorch, dude.
I need to, because I got back to a corner.
Stupid reasons.
I know how to finish.
Oh, maybe a triple.
Don't hide behind the fucking boxes.
Let me shoot you.
It takes me a while to do the fucking animation.
Jesus.
You have something that I need.
You look lonely.
I can fix that.
Keep these guys off your back.
It's all you from here on out.
Okay, thank you.
Cooper, we're tracking Blisk and Sloan just ahead.
Ow.
They have the arc.
Keep moving.
What the...
What?
What the fuck was that?
I got knocked into the hole.
I don't even fucking know anywhere.
I don't even know.
That was not me.
That was weird.
I don't even know.
Target's locked.
Fire it.
He's hiding down.
Hahahahahaha
Yeah
Think I do
Oh
It was this Legion that's who it was. I didn't know what happened to you before
If we fail
I didn't mean to press smart core, but it wasn't doing anything for
Bodying bitches come on cutie pies
I don't know why you think you can do this something about me
I have a front shield are you fucking serious why didn't I fucking notice that?
I'm actually pissed
I don't know I never fucking pressed that before
Initiating targeting systems harmony coordinates to six four point five eight eight recorded
What if I just stand here? Well harmony just die
Just like
What's that place? Oh, no, oh, sorry, excuse me. Oh, I'm so sorry
No, why is it making me almost up on Marvin's?
You have your money blizz now go my forces will take over from here that time they do something
Yeah, that's boring cuz I'm gonna do a double
I'm gonna kill the fuck out of you guys
Come on in come on. Let's do this you little book
Can actually I can walk behind something
Really making me work from up
Really she just sent other people after me passing stage two coordinates locked report system planetary
I forget I can run
Oh
Forge, bro
Don't let this high-pitched know it what bitch get out of the way. I'm busy
Sorry
You're probably gonna kill me before I kill you
You think a couple of Reapers are gonna do something I don't maybe they will cuz I'm pretty low health right now
Oh, that's pretty nifty. I like this
Thanks
I like that
Of course you're right where I need
You're back into it join the fight. I'm a little busy. Oh, perfect
I forgot gun shield exists and nothing matters
Oh my god, she's gonna fucking end me. Oh my god
No, you don't you don't you don't get to hit me
No
I'm gonna be sorry mate time to die
I don't even know where that brute went
It's nice to try love but I'm no pushover
I
Get him lads imagine landing in and then just fucking dying that must suck
I feel like the scorches have
Oh, sorry, I have to reload not the best timing there
We work on
Why do you teleport how do you even do that?
Sold weapon passing stage three calculating space for projection
Say good night, you little bastard
I'll give you a
This year your hand
I
Sorry, I'm like so quiet because I'm locked in at least they're like kind of walking the same animation. Yeah, there we go
You're almost done. I'll give you a hero
Warning expected backblast energy reaching lethal threshold all personnel must clear the chamber immediately
Disruption of electromechanical units including titans will be severe
You
No, sorry, I got a clicky
Oh, did I have to hold me?
Are you gonna die again bt? I'm not happy
I'm I've been crying this entire time
Bt
I don't work for free
But
Now we team up and get to kill me either because I have something that you want
a cigarette you earn design
What the fuck is that?
That man got class titan is still in there. Get that out of my face
Should have put it in my contract
I've got other people get that actually out of my face. What are you doing?
Get this john apex man out of my face
Yeah
As I go and go play like apex like a month from now or something. I don't know
I don't want to see I don't want to look at this. Hey, like it's it's it's disrespectful
Cooper I require your assistance if I auto navigation systems are offline get me into that injector assembly
We must do this together
W do I hold it? I don't know it doesn't tell me
Why do I have to do anything everything you are absolutely useless
I can't do it. I can't deal with this emotional stress
I'm holding w just in case because I don't know what's happening. We're just killing ourselves
Oh
Don't worry bt. I'm not going anywhere. I'm I'll kill myself with you
I know that goes against her programming, but protocol three protect the pilot
No, I knew we were gonna fucking do this
I
Like I remember this happening and it still hurts
No, I'm killing myself
I can't do this
I need a tissue
I knew it was coming like I forget that they like
I do remember this part and it's annoying as fuck
Like why this is at least let me take out your fucking eye first
Just just fucking kill me just fucking kill me. Ow my ankles are broken. Oh, but my jump kit. Yeah, whatever
I don't even know where I'm running to see you know what I don't even have a will to live
I
Pull up to call because that's what to say. Oh, yeah, I'll protect the pilot. Oh, just kidding
Don't tell strong you play this game because she'll cry she'll cry harder than I am
What the I can't even tell what's happening
I'm jumping for it
How
Thanks ugly makeup lady you look like
You have very bad concealer under your eyes
I do like the like the black Korean glass skin look you're going for though
Oh my god
So bt died for nothing
I
That's what you're telling me right that bt died for nothing
Because a planet still exploded pilot cooper a lot of people owe their lives to you
And to bt shut up. You don't get to say his name
Set a course for harmony. Take us home. You got it
That's right. That's right. His core just stabilized it. So it exploded the planet the destruction of typhans saved the planet harmony
The militia calls this planet their headquarters
The millions of others call it home
Like how it's mostly green so the blue be inducted into the marauder core and assigned a new titan
After the tax wipe what's left of my neural link with bt. I don't care. No, I don't know what that'll feel like
to get assigned a new titan
I kind of like the old one
This is pilot jack cooper signing off
Matt Mercer the fact you weren't fucking balling in the stew
Such a great fucking campaign
I'm the second vtb to come
Oh, wow, they actually fucking show him
Why does he look latino
Don't dapp her up
She literally looks like
stereotypical
Uh, what's that fucking amazing like that famous poster? It's like
Women for the army poster like something. Oh, I forgot her name
It literally looks like her
Looks like mirage. Uh, no
Does not look like mirage at all. Oh, I thought you meant her. Yes. He actually kind of does look like mirage. You're not wrong
I didn't say anything's wrong with latinos. I said he looks latino
They're all just mirage. This is all just this is all mirage
Yes, rosy rivets
I'm so upset
Yes, she did like why is he celebrating
I would be so torn in the emotional attachment. I formed with a robot in the span of a couple hours
The more I look at him the more it looks like a mirage with a different haircut
I
Actually think it's the same model except the different haircut
Technically a part of bt's core. Yeah, that's what I mean because he still has the gun
And he still has the helmet and everything and they have to wipe his neural link
And so that's why it's obviously showing like oh bt lives on in the helm. Wait
Excuse me. What? Okay. So yeah bt's still alive
Thank you optimus. You're amazing
Right the game of
Oh my god, it's rockamos. He's dead. He had like five seconds of screen time
Um music production 10 out of 10 voice acting
8 out of 10
uh game overall
Because it has such a soft spot in my heart
Go away. I cannot stand your face. Um
I would say a year and all mommy. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes
I will vote about your twitter
your
Character design is honestly really cool
Like I like canes
Design of his Titan
Thank you again for another 10 gifted Ray kuma. Oh my god dropping them like it's hot this motherfucker
Make sure you say thank you if you got something
Thank you. Thank you
Overall I also yeah, the vipers. I think vipers is actually my favorite
The enemy titans are so fucking cool fuck Sloan
Poor derogatory
I
Would say time falls like an 8 out of 10 for me
Just because like I like when it first came out like it was a 10 out of 10 like but it's falling from grace and EA's ruined everything
I
Just a guy that likes to fight. I don't know. I was he like for hire. I
Like kind of like the halo reach team we had fucking have a
Little little destiny squad me squatting up with the boys. He's like come on
I'm Davis. Come on, bro. Come on cameraman. Follow us
It's like cod the cod squad I am seething
Who are you I don't remember you
Who else does Yuri lo and fall voice
I
Be so cool to just be a rando and PC I'd be like
Playing tight it was pretty damn sick
Yeah
Her daughter, what do you mean? I don't know the lore of
Of time fall everyone only play the game for the game
I never pay attention to the lore like I do now for games like if I was like Ellen ring
I'd be like what's going like I'm probably actually gonna watch a whole war video about time and fall after this
Just so you know
I'm yeah, like I don't know like they would like EA would make even more money if they dropped Titanfall 3
I don't understand what's going through their heads that they won't do it. I'm still crying
Like it doesn't like they're we all know they love money
They'll make even more
If they dropped Titanfall 3 just let respawn do what they need to do
Well, I don't know any of that stuff. I don't know anything about apex anymore
I only played when it first came out for like a couple of months
Excuse me, and I I I mained bloodhound
Valkyrie is Viper's daughter. Yeah, but I don't know who Valkyrie is
Is that a character in apex? I don't know I haven't played apex and like I got on apex
I think also like a year ago. I played one match and I was like nah, I'm good
I'm okay
Respawn are the ones that don't want to make Titanfall 3 too bad. Do it anyways me a vtuber who you don't know or have any
Loven affection for is telling you to do so because it would make a lot of people's childhood. Please respawn
I'm begging you. I use so much. I want to take in fall 3 game
Okay, Viper has a daughter's one of the legends apex with the name of Valkyrie and that's what she did was copy your father's Titan design
Coping so hard. What do you mean? I'm not cool. I'm shit at the game. I don't I never I never said I was good at apex
When it first came out. Yeah, because I like I'm always very good at games when they first came out like when fortnight came out
I was good
But rainbow came out. Actually, no, that's a lie. I never did. I never really played rainbow
I think CS was one of the only games I like
Started obviously like to see us like my dad has been fucking playing CS go. I'm sorry. Just smack the mic
I'm here. Sorry Rena jumped to my arms. Hi
Are you trying to calm me down?
I'm getting so he did
Um, oh
Yeah, I am yes
I you know, yeah, I think they all disbanded. I think respawn is all I don't think respawn's the company that
That it was before
I'm pretty much the mic times do
Who knows there's I heard there's rumors of a half-life 3 so
Frontier defense isn't leaving me myself
Perfectly fine. I'm not I
disagree
Highly disagree. I
Think a third installment would wrap it up very nicely
Yeah, right, yeah, cuz didn't the didn't respawn technically close and they're just using the name and the branding
Hello, welcome
Beach he's alive
Pilot pilot come in
What does he fucking possess the helmet? Oh my god
Even my cats. Oh, yeah, no, Rena always usually um
Checks on me when I get like stressed out. She's my girl. I motion or support kitty. Yeah
Yeah
Emotion or support kitty
Oh
The Morse code read does jack jack. Are you there? Oh, that's funny. I think I remember seeing that somewhere
Ever gone about that. Have a good night. Bye. Bye
She says
Become a multiplayer that'll kill TFG's multiplayer. What are you?
But it will just be even a better multiplayer. Let's let's see multiplayer. Let's see how bad I am
Ignore that my wait. No, I actually know it shouldn't be my
Oh, I'll see if it's we'll see what name it shows. Don't add me. I'm not gonna add you back. Sorry kids
What
What the fuck is this
I
Don't even know what the fuck is happening
Again, I played Titanfall one mostly I've played the campaign of Titanfall two multiple times
I
Is that the cloak I don't
Know what I'm looking at
Multiplayer is pretty all right as high chance to counter crack players. You never put down the game
me no, I'm kidding. Um
Fuck a spitfire
Let's just do that. Why would I want a charge rifle? Can I change that? Do I have to pick one?
Oh
That's right because you need the anti Titan
That's right. I prefer fuck. I can't get it. It costs money. Oh wait, I have
Nobody look at my name
Um
Can I buy it? Oh
Does that level it up if I
Unlocks the level 32 the wingman's the best fucking
Gone in the game. Uh, whatever. I don't nobody look at my name shut up. Um
If you add me I will block your ass I can be female
I don't oh, I'm just I'm just a twink. All right, that's fine. Uh
neckbreaker
Grand theft seven what no, I want to see what it looks like. Don't I do they not offer previews like fucking apex?
Wait, I can change the color. Hold on. Is that like the skins? Can I please edit stuff?
Grapple
cloak
tactical
Oh, I did because I remember I did like that because bloodhound and shit
I do remember using the grapple. I remember. Okay. I do remember some of these
This is just mirage
I'll stick with the grapple because I'm stupid. Uh, let's see what we got
The ugliest skins known to man. What about some like cool shit, but the super expensive stuff ugly ugly ugly. Wow. These are
Disgusting
That's pretty neat
I'm not spending my whatever coins I have on this though. I'm not doing that. Um, I don't know what these blocked
Oh mods
I don't care
I know skins equals wins
Do you guys want to hop in do you guys want to play multiplayer?
How do we
How do we do that?
Happy hour, what the fuck is this is the only people that are online right now is that because that's funny
In box
I don't know what that means. I don't know what an advocate gift is
I'm an advocate. I don't know. Uh, who am I advocating for?
Who still has this game downloaded and fight network
Private match
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I don't know what that means. Let's not do that
Let's let's let's
I don't how would I my networks? Isn't this like
Isn't that like a
Freaking I am the advocate
What I don't know what that is
Fine game
Okay
Never explain this again. No wait actually explain it again. How do I cancel?
I don't want to hear people
Hold on. I don't want to hear people at all. I don't want to
Know voice chat, how do I turn off voice chat?
You don't have it on pc. Okay, that's fine. You know what I'll just I'll play one
I'll play
I'll play one Titanfall multiplayer game and then I'll play one apex game
Can I just play attrition?
Can I
There's 2,000 players on
Let's see. Let's see how trash I am
I I'm muted voice chat
So I should be fine, right?
Rena's laying on my hand
Still more than Concord
Damn
That's harsh
Is your mic muted
I don't want to be myself
I don't want to be myself guys
Guys, how do I move myself?
Guys, I don't
How do I
Oh, that scared me
Oh
You
Oh, this is an old I do recommend oh, it's angel city
I sound like a fucking old woman
Oh
I've never played
Ready
Okay pilots, let's get this job done
Do we have any pilots in the area? I'm scared
Got visual over here
Oh
I have to whisper
Bro
Oh
Oh, there's radar
Are you kidding me? I'm like five health
Oh
He knows I'm in here
Are you
We're falling behind let's pull it together team
Oh
I'm definitely near spawn point though
Guys, uh
I don't know oh I have to freaking call it in are you serious?
I don't know all my weapons
Ah, oh rena you fucking clogged my tip
Oh
Oh, it's my time it's my time guys, it's my time
Where did my team go
All right
They're just wrongs I want an accurate person
No
Yes, I know I'm not using any of my stuff I could be using
I'm killing myself
And I just quit can I leave I'm already done. I don't want to do this anymore. Ah, you scared me
Terrified
I have zero kills
Not so sure I didn't mean to throw that
I meant to do this
I know most of the fight. Oh my god. What am I doing?
This is a start to me being an amazing Titanfall player
And
Everybody will want to hang out with me. Oh no
I'm just gonna sit here for the rest of this stuff. I haven't killed one person
I told you I wasn't I'm not good at yes these guys
Someone saw me
Oh
All I hear are Titans. Oh, this is a bad idea
Oh, what are you doing? Oh, they were trying to knife me. That's not nice
I got one kill guys are you proud because they were trying to creep up on me because I'm bad
I don't really know
I see people
Am I good enough to kill them? It's feasible
What
Oh
I wanted manically the top 20% with one player. So yeah, it's my time. I'm gonna kill these guys
Is there a dude behind me?
Oh no
Most
Bro, I always hate when they land your Titan and kill you with a Titan. I was backed into a fucking corner
That's a fucking specter. That's why I'm able to hit it
Is there like actual people I can fight?
No, not a Titan. No, I'm stuck in there again
I
Think I carried that bro
I think I carried that bro
I slip into my doki impression. What are you talking about?
It's all right. I'm gonna redeem myself with apex. No, I'm not. It's gonna be worse. Let's let's try. Let's try one match
one match
One match
Can I what the fuck am I looking at?
I
Let's try let's
Let's try
My voice slips into it
Does it I don't mean to
Because my voice does like get to the back of my throat and a little bit nasally when I'm
Like playing games sometimes. Um
Again, my voice changes a lot. Oh, it's got a shiver
Apex legends
Except I have to download the game. I swear it's already downloaded
Can I just
Huh all right
How long is this gonna take?
55 minutes
Okay, it's going down
Yeah, thanks Franks for hanging up. Yeah, I was just I was just a warm-up guys. I was just a warm-up
It was just a warm-up, you know
I'm pretty I'm pretty cool with it right rena rena's impressed with my with my prowess. I killed that one guy
Did you see that?
I killed I killed a top frag
I don't know if he was top frag. I killed I killed a man
My model is lagging because I'm downloading stuff and it's it's saying it's taking 30 minutes, but it's going down
It just went up to 30 again
um
This is a bad idea. I thought I already had this installed
Okay, we're not we're not we're not doing this
Why can't I send messages my own fucking stream?
Oh queen
Oh god. Oh, I didn't mean to close my own. I I'm gone now. I accidentally closed vtube studio
My back. Hello
Guys
Am I still here? Hold on. I gotta reload
Everything's explode. Hello. Oh, there I am
Just
Staring at you. All right. That was a bad idea. We're not doing that. Um
Yeah, like one guy was trying to execute me because he knew how bad I was so that's fine
Uh, I'm a time pulp fault pro make sure you spread that so I get invited to tournaments and stuff
And then people can see how wonderful I am at tinefall
Uh, didn't touch the game for a year and I was already top frag. So it's pretty crazy
How I just have that like natural FPS touch, you know
Um
I'm gone
Oh, I think there's latency now
I think there's a lot of latency now
latency now
Uh guys, I'm still here guys
Oh my god, there's okay. There's like a 10 second delay. I think guys refresh the stream refresh the stream, please
Refresh it
I'm scratching my eye
Uh
What time is it? I want to play Elden Ring. I didn't think I'd
It's slowly catching up to life
Well
Maybe I should just end stream. Maybe this is a sign that I should just end it all
on stream
in tinefall
Uh
I am MLG contender, you know, I have been scouted by like phase cloud nine
liquid
you know
Trying to think of more places I'm a sort of mythic mythic talent
um
Uh
But uh, yeah, I'm a I'm a pretty pro player
Uh fanatic precisely if ESPO is just waiting to snatch me up. Sadly, my heart is taken by veeler
It's not gonna happen
But you know, they they tried they tried their best to get me
Uh, because I'm a very sought after FPS player
But um, but yeah, it's just it's just not a phase bun
It's just not that, you know, the way the cookie crumbles. I'm playing like I'm petting rena's paws. Her paws are so soft
Oh my god, your paws are so soft
Your little toe beans rena
Um
I was uh, yeah, yeah, I finished time fall too. I'm just talking about how wonderful I am at streaming
Um, it's the FPS is I'm gonna have to get my reps up
If I'm telling you
I was good once. I mean, I'm great now, but I was good once, you know, we all take steps
To like figure out where we are in life and try to figure out
You know
Ourselves in our play. I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about. Uh, let's try let me find somebody to read
I have I just have people like leaving I get
I just see my view count going down as I'm fucking rambling
Um, I don't know
Where is why isn't letting me edit. Oh, it signed me out
Of youtube what the fuck
Why did it sign me out
Hold on I have to log back in
I
Hate it here
I'm here guys. I'm here
Wait did it end stream
Did it just end stream the stream just die
I will literally cry if stream just ended
Okay, no, it didn't okay, it's okay. I got scared
I have to be like I can't handle this now
Right now your paws are so nice you show off
Okay, so who do we got we got
Mercy is playing chain together with some girly pops
Uh, let me just read mercy
And uh go have fun with mercy. She's playing with uh, me akumia
Uh, I forget where she's from. I can't remember if she's from an agency or not. Um, I like that. She's playing
She's playing
Like I wonder what the dynamic is when it's just like two people because I've only ever played with like three or more
Like with uh, like the girls like apollo and azura and um
Oh the other girls
Let me okay. I did it. It's fine
And freya
Your fresh the special light that's what I thought I'm like, I think it's special light because my name sounds super familiar
All right. Well, I'll be seeing you
Uh, I hope you still love me after today
Uh, I hope you still you guys can't see what I'm doing my like putting my fingers together like
Like please and I'm like I'm like I'm like lin-win-well more Miranda like with my
With my knees turned in and my toes like pointing and stuff
um
Like I'm getting my fps fps fps wraps up because I want to play the new cod
uh
Because again, I'm I'm the best when games first come out
Once I like drop them for a little bit that I just don't play them and I end up turning into shit. Um, I don't know
I don't know why I do that
but uh
I hope you guys liked it. I hope it was entertaining
I don't know
Good time
And again, I like fps is like I like locking in. Um, gonna. Yeah, I'm gonna prestige 100%
um, I don't know how that's a comfy stream when I'm like
Talking about stomping on people but yeah, um
I'm so sleepy. It's almost 12 p.m. 12 p.m. 12 a.m. Oh my god. I don't know where I am
uh, I might
If uh, it says I did my errands today. I'll probably maybe I'll play Elden Ring tomorrow morning
I don't know if you guys want to watch. I'm probably just fucked around and like
I don't know
Let's do grindy shit. I don't really
Know if that'll be entertaining sometimes I just
Sometimes it's actually hard to like play a game when you have to talk over it a lot
Sometimes I just want to sit there and just be like
Say nothing
Like that I sometimes I was afraid because like when I do fps is I don't talk as much because I'm like, um,
I'm kind of more focused
It kind of requires a little bit more brain power for me. And so I take that and I
And I'm still shit. So you understand
Stomping doesn't really chill gaming but rena, why are you stretching out and getting all comfy on me though?
I'm gonna get up soon. Ha, ma'am
Why are you so cute?
You're extra cute today rena with your little with your little hammy legs. Oh, no, give me your foot back
I want it. Give me your foot back. Give me your foot
She just took it away from me. She like she just yanked it
I had a blash man. Um, my favorite was when the enemy fire said the first time using that gun pellet
Explodes
Thank you stash
But it was pretty funny
Yeah, it depends on the game, uh, you know
I do like I like I'm not good at
Game like I wish I was like cracked at a game
Like that like I think maybe like another one of my goals is to be like
Cracked at a game because I've never like been like really exceptional at a game
And it bothers me because like I'll play a game
I'll pour so many hours into a game
But then I just like won't be the level that I want to be at and I wonder what I do wrong in those cases
I really do because I'm like, okay. I've put in the training
I've put in the hours
I've learned the lore
What else is there? What do I got to do? What do I need to do?
Oh my god, the frames are dropping
exponentially
Um, oh cons playing street. That's cool. I've never played a fight. I'm game. Well, no, that's a lie. I've have played
I've never played on stream
Like a fighting game because I don't I'm not a huge fan of them because I mostly just spam so I don't
I'm not really good with the combo shit
Maybe one day you can do a speedrun of any game, but like what game would I even speed?
There's no game that I good I'm good at that I would speed run
Um
Yeah, I have to play for addition different ambition to join the and but like that's that's kind of why I played
Counter strike because I I played to get good. I didn't play because I liked it
I think that's why a lot of league players play their games. Um
So I think yeah, maybe that's why I was a little bit more successful
um
But yeah, have fun hanging out super mara 64. No
Ow I'm like
I don't know if I got a bug bite on my chin or something hurts arena
Maybe
Your face looks so funny me and my mom cut bit by bugs. We were in the garden
What's up with your face when I do this? Are you kidding? What happened to your head? Did you scratch your head rena?
What did you do?
You look like a little little lamb
Oh, I could eat lamb not you though rena. I wouldn't eat you. You're too precious
You're too precious to be eaten
You don't have to be good. They're animals games are done. You just have to follow. No, I want to be good
I want to be excellent. That's why I'm trying very hard to be excellent not excellent, but like okay at elden ring
I would prefer it to be an fps, but I love like elden ring is actually just like
A passion of mine at this point. I've been
You know all I do when I'm not streaming and not recording as I just watch elden ring videos
And walkthroughs and gameplay and speed runs and randomizers. That's all I do
And then I watch like game grumps and then I'll watch like mark a fire
Uh, and then I'll watch some vtubers naturally
Like my gen mates like that's all I do. That's I don't
That's all I do is elden ring
um
A game or yeah, I'm getting cracked in a game arc
You know what? So my my goal for september by the way, I want to work on uh health and fitness
So I don't know where to what to do with that, but um
I think maybe like
I'll have a goal to do a certain amount of squats because you know I get need to get those butt reps up
You know, um
Do like an exercise
You know, because I I've been so sedentary and I'm not like my body's not used to it
Because I used to always be on my feet for my job
And so I'm like, all right, let's let's pick up the slack. Let's let's do some shit. So that'll be a goal
And then september so it'll be
Get and I have a gym in my in my building. So I'll probably yeah, I said treadmill
Walking one of those walking treadmills would be super cool. Um, but I don't have like a stint like a
Like a raised desk for that that would be if I like one of those crazy desks
So those are like thousands of dollars. My god. Um, and I don't want one
And then
Because I have like a treadmill. Yeah in the gym and then uh
And then get cracked at a game
Do you know how how much willpower it's taking me not to only play elden ring guys?
And it's funny because I wasn't even going to play elden ring at all until you guys asked me to
Because I was gonna play everything by myself
And now all I want to do is stream elden ring
I that's why I was like, oh, I'm gonna stream elden ring this morning
But like I got caught up in stuff in my tummy horts like it is right now
And now all I want to do is just stream elder like I was like debating whether or not to ask
Like management if I could just make a whole channel just dedicated to elden ring
No, but that's shit for growth. There's a channel and I'm a mostly asmr. Well, I'm not mostly asmr
um
Goal is asmr
uh
Vindy elden ring for no, I don't I don't have the I would I would ruin my sleep schedule
um
But
Yeah, maybe tomorrow I'll play
Maybe I'll nap for like an hour and then get up
And then play by myself
I just love elden ring so much. I was listening when I was doing my errand
I was listening about lore about godwin the golden the night of the black knives
Okay, although it was from two years ago. So it's a little inaccurate, but I kind of want to finish it because that's pretty good
Because I was learning more about godwin because I don't know a lot about godwin because I like I made me start thinking
That's why I wanted to like brute force the like night that was in the place where godwin was in that one graveyard
Or the graveyard that one catacomb. So
Yeah
No, I played sacro I I played I have sacro
um
I played it once and
That was a technically the first souls game. I played
And I didn't understand what a souls like was I was like, oh cool
Like feudal era japan game get me in and then I couldn't beat the first boss
Like that one dude. So I never touched again. Now. I think I could probably beat him
Um
It would be maybe I'll do a week where I just do from soft game. So I'll do like blood born lies of pee. I love lies of pee
um
My little my little twink puppet
uh
Dark souls I think dark souls 3 is the best one, right? I don't know. Uh, maybe demon souls
Black myth wukong armored core
From soft. No not from soft. I said souls likes not from soft game
recipe is not from soft
No, it's not right
No, it's made by a korean company
No, we're not doing crabs treasure. I'm
The input lag from crabs treasure piss me off. I could not stand it
So
I was not that difficult. It was your first one. Yeah, but I didn't know the understanding the concept of one of those games
You get to click it to click or not. Yeah, I don't know. I was so revisit secaro 100 percent
Uh, sorry to hear it's fine. It's fine. All right, go on go on to mercy. It's already been an hour
I'll send you over
Yeah, I know I'd have to get a capture card for bloodborne. It's such a pain because he still won't port it over
Let me take off my headphones. Um, thank you guys for the dough. No doesn't get the subs today. You guys are amazing
I'm gonna go take a fat sleep
um
Rain is grooming herself on me. I gotta put this ball of ranch away. I just got a bottle of ranch next to my desk
And then fee and boomi are probably knocked out somewhere
Well fee is obviously the same spot. I think boomi is also sleeping on the couch near her
Which is very sweet and cute
Unless she's stealing something
Yeah
um
But yeah
Well, I don't know if that's gonna be a thing. It was just like because I like I like theme weeks. They're kind of fun
Um, and then it also will forces forces me to introduce new games into my
Like what I normally use because like maybe I'll do like a retro
week
um, so I do like maybe like Mario 64 or like old
Nintendo games or
Like do a little bit more vampire the masquerade or the old do
Crash Bandicoot
I could play one of my favorite old, um
Gba games
Which was um
So my dad was very cool
And we were when I was younger we were my parents like they had me young
They married or young
All that stuff
But my dad still wanted me to like have the love of video games because my dad always loved video games
so he
Built an emulator into my into the family computer
And so I was able to he was able to emulate like all gba games and game boy games
In some ds games. And so I remember playing uh crazy racers
Which was like really bad knockoff Mario Kart
Um
Yeah, it was pretty as that was I remember I loved playing that game
And I would it's it was so goofy
And I haven't revisited that game in such a long time
I also remember playing like
Like Prince of Persia on that like my dad pulled like so many games that were like so past my time
So that's why I'm a little bit more cultured when it comes to games. Although not really
Because like I would try like a game once and I'd be like, oh never mind. Um
God, that's so my beloved. Yeah, but my dad. Yeah, my dad
um
My parents tried a lot. I also was a kid who didn't want a lot
My mom would be like
You want a toy from a toy store and I'm like
I would like
One stuffed animal and they're like we literally offered you anything you want and I'm like once I would like this
stuffed animal, please
My parents are like what the hell's wrong with our child? Um
But yeah
Love god of war. Uh, you know
I have god of war ragnarok on my playstation. I had never played a god of war game
Uh
I played a little bit of ragnarok, but I just got bored with it
I don't know why
Like sometimes if I get distracted by other things I and it's not super capturing my interest in the beginning
Then I don't play it like I played
Uh, there's there's a couple of games like that on my playstation that I just didn't finish
That's because it's on me
gta 5 store, uh
I remember playing why I didn't play I remember watching kids play like gta when I like was at school
But I never I have a number gta or which gta it was
um
Uh, I've actually never played gta
Like I have the game
There's a lot of games I have but I've never played
um
I usually buy them when they're on sale like I know drop ragnarok for elden ring. No, I like
Did I drop ragnarok for elden ring?
Maybe I did
Yeah, I did actually technically
Yeah, because I got like because I bought the ragnarok bundle for the playstation 5
And then elden ring came out
And I was playing ragnarok and then I play yeah, so I I I guess I did drop ragnarok for elden ring
I knew it and then I literally was
I was so
Hooked like I had like
the
I haven't had a hyper fixation like that and like I still like it came back which is rare
Like I usually don't come back to hyper fixations like they just they're tucked away
nicely
Uh in the corner of my heart in my mind because like I really like um
I had a hyper fixation on snakes and spiders for a long time
But like I'll go and like I'll watch like maybe like a snake
patching review
Just because because I like to see like what like the genetic odds are of stuff
but then like but for elden ring like it just
Constantly like the lord it's really all comes down to the world building the character development
And the lore that's I think that's why and then like with god or ragnarok. Yeah, it's based on
Like mythology and stuff, but I don't know maybe because it's its own worlds
Elden ring, I don't know why elden ring sets itself apart for other things for me
I was like probably one of my favorite games of all time
um
I wasn't exit. No. Yeah, I just I I couldn't tell you why
Like because I literally I used to play like ttt on gary's mod
Hold on. I'm gonna go on my steam right now and I'll look at my library
I'll play brawl hollow I would play counter strike
See his go
I would play destiny, but I mostly plays at him play station
I played skyrim
I would play like pub g and stuff too. I liked pub g
I used to play fortnite for like a little bit a lot of stuff was like if a friend was like friends
We're like, hey, you want to play it? I'm like, yeah
And then I would like just be carried the entire time because I'm shit
And I just perpetuate that woman or shit a video game stereotype inscription was good
I think maybe I liked inscription because the lore base and this the especially unique
I never played a deck builder before
Um, I have outlast. What did I get at? When did I get outlast?
I do not recall. I never played it though
I remember playing project winter for a little bit
Yeah
I'm freaking wolf quest. I was always on wolf quest
but I have
I just fucking love elden ring so much
I think I like elden ring maybe because it reminds me a lot of skyrim
Although it's not the same, but you know what I mean
I know I I saw a ball uh ballotro
Ball I want to call it ball taro because the preacher that's how strong he pronounces it, but that's not correct
I want to play block bail lotro ballotro
um
Because strong you like
hyperfixated on it for a little bit and I was like, hmm interesting
And I like for a little bit
I was actually into hearthstone, which is really weird for me because I usually am not into like that sort of stuff
Um, again, I love like lore character role building all that shit. I've never played dnd in my life
um
Never did a dnd d dnd dnd campaign
I have balder's gate on my playstation. I only played for three hours
And I'm like, when do I get to fuck the vampire dude? Like that's all I'm playing for I bought this for this reason
I saw
The one trailer of that guy
Uh sleeping with the druid that like went viral and I was like, I want this game
I think this would be funny that you can do that. I want to play it
And then I played it. I'm like, what am I do? I have no idea what I'm doing
There's so much stuff that I don't know and I blame my dad
Clean up my dad likes that stuff
Oh
Skyrim the latest god of war. Yeah, they're nordic mythology and I love norse mythology. Norse mythology is super cool
That's why I like like vikings and like the last kingdom and stuff. It's really like I love
um
I also like this like historical fiction or like period pieces are super cool to me
Uh, I think that's why I like lies of pee because it was like
Victorian london or like england or whatever. Although it's really not. It's just like fake same with like bloodborne
I've never played bloodborne, but it's so aesthetically pleasing for me
I'd probably become just obsessed with bloodborne has uh, I do my obsession with elden ring
Be alert d&d can't be like who would be the master though like who would do that?
Like I'm pretty good at improv
um
I don't know about the other girls. Mercy's pretty decent at improv
I don't think I would want it like I would want to be the dungeon master
But because I've never done it before I don't think I should be the dungeon master
Um
But I watched that one clip of that like famous
Well, she's not famous like she's like normal celebrity
Um, she used to be on true blood one of my favorite guilty pleasure shows about vampires
Or she plays a vamp like the our ride headed vampire girl
And there's a clip of her explaining how she likes to like how she's a dungeon master for d&d
And how like her games of d&d flow and she like literally brings in
um
Like she was really talking to the guy who plays the punisher because she you know, she plays
What's her face and dare devil
and
Something burnt all I can't remember his name too. His last name is burnt all so she's telling burnt all like oh
This is what I do like you hear this and I love that clip and I'm like I want to do d&d
But it's like the character sheets and stuff like always overwhelm me because I'm not good at math
I never played metal gear solid
Guys, there's a lot of games. I haven't played that I own like I oh like I you can't see I'm doing parentheses like I own
I like your solid thanks to my dad
And my dad has like crisis and stuff and like a bunch of other games
I like playstation in the basement
Plans of supplies to have fun, isn't it? Yeah, I bet
You know, I wouldn't be surprised if like there's been a lot of like unity related stuff lately in the vtuber community
Because you have like the gta rp server
Uh, you've had the mario kart
And the minecraft stuff. I wouldn't be surprised if somebody tried to do like a group d&d thing
I generally wouldn't be surprised again. I don't know if we'd be invited, but you know, it is what it is with
One day we'll be invited to stuff. Um, and I I'll be patient even if we never do like we'll make our own
Our own fun memories and stuff
Uh battlefield one. Yeah, I liked um
Uh
What was the I can't remember what the most recent
Oh, never mind. I can't think of it
Um, I'm yeah, I'm losing what I'm talking about because I'm tired
So I'm gonna go to bed tell mercy. I say hello. Um
Um
I wish I could be like chains and whips excite me raid. No, don't say that just say just say she be raid or sleepy she be raid
I don't know. Whatever you want. I can't this is too much pressure coming up with raid
Messages guys. I can't
I can't do it
We're in the third false good. What does that mean?
Bt bt raid say bt raid just say bt
She be x bt raid or a bt raid, whichever. Yeah, whichever you prefer. We need to honor bt
We need to honor him
We care about him. We care about a sacrifice
Um, yeah, have a good night guys
You still smell bad
I don't even have to like like sniff because I can like smell you from here. My eyes are watering. It's pretty crazy
Um, but you know, I still I love you nonetheless
even with your
Your stinkiness, I suppose
Uh, I know I shower today. I don't know what you guys
I think it's my tomagotchi did let's check
I
Don't be sleeping. That's fun
But you always say that I shower not well not well enough not well enough
You say you shower what you think I'm the offer proof. Oh, you guys are silly. All right later
And nerds. I'm like not even gonna bother with it end screen
Later nerds
Boo we rest in peace bt
You can't see I did like the knock on the chest kiss my fingers and then need the peace sign
You know and just point up to the heavens because that's where bt is
Um, if I believe in that, uh, bye-bye
RIP bt
Okay, have a good night guys get some sleep hang out with mercy if you're still like, um
Have some of your day left. Make sure you hydrate stretch get some water
Get done what you need to get done
You know take care of yourselves. Okay. All right
Take care of each other too kisses
I know sometimes we we are in times of uncertainty
And you guys don't know what's quite going on
Um, but just know that we work on stuff
And not everything will be okay. Okay. I don't want you to worry. I don't want you to fret
You will be all right
And I will be all right
And Viola will be all right. I care about you all. Thank you